control of what's going on
and not always be waiting on Concord to
approve their projects we currently have
17 projects on the list three of which
are approved there's several hundred
million dollars that aren't approved and
it's unlikely that those will get
approved in any time frame and even if
they're approved sometimes the voters in
the Local District district don't
approve it so sometimes the schools
aren't billed this would allow the money
to go directly to the schools in a much
more expeditious fashion
I'm willing to take any questions on
this if there are any right
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
good morning thank you Jr I'm sorry
representative Jr that works thank you
thank you
um
Charter Schools what uh is that going to
be funded the same way yes so um if you
look at lines 17 and 18
um right
um Charter Schools would be recipients
of this other than vlax vlax is a little
bit of an anomaly because vlax is a
virtual classroom unlike all the other
charter schools that have some physical
facility they need to be meet somewhere
part of this is every kid who's in a
classroom needs a classroom to learn
somewhere whether it's
um a classroom in the traditional school
or in a charter school
um
even parents who homeschool have a
classroom they pay for it themselves
this doesn't impact the homeschoolers at
all it wasn't intended to this was
strictly for the public school students
162 approximately 162 000 students that
are in the public school system
but this allows the students to have the
local school board to have some money
available to help out the student in
terms of large capital projects
follow up
the charter schools you know I have a
really the base or the fix number of
students to in other words a even to
rent a place I mean it's very expensive
and
this you know I mean it's they just
won't uh it won't cover it won't even
cover a mortgage if they have to buy a
place
I mean even even over time it uh because
you know if they have 200 students
that's 50 000 that's that's going to be
very
if they have 200 students right it would
be closer to sixty thousand dollars it's
it's a K-8 Charter School let's do that
as a hypothetical at 300 a student that
would be sixty thousand dollars that
sixty thousand dollars that charter
school isn't is not getting today that
could be available for at least
classrooms
um least office space is something like
twelve dollars a square foot right now
um commercial office space so right uh
follow up
um now does this cover over the full 12
years is this designed to cover the full
12 years of the student
he needs a classroom and this is
designed to be the way we should move
forward so we're incentivizing and
giving the local school boards control
of how they manage their facilities
right and how much do we have to fund is
it 51 million dollars a year over the
over the 12 years I mean it's going to
have to be changed it might be changed
but this is right those numbers right
now are based on based on the 300 350
would be 51 million dollars
um it is possible future legislatures
could increase that number and
um
it it's a little bit of a departure from
where we have been in terms of building
Aid and the reason it's a departure is
the current system has some fundamental
flaws in terms of of the development
process to get approval it it it's it's
years not weeks and months follow-up now
will it save any other any money in
other places uh such as having to go and
inspect the schools and uh you know put
do this ranking system and it wouldn't
it would
unravel some of the The Rat's Nest
relative to the approval process today
you you go you start a process you put
together a proposal you have some design
work done you then send it over to
conquer they look at it they evaluate it
that process takes some time
unfortunate unfortunately it gives the
current process gives the doe very
little time is my understanding to
review the final application at the
board of ed level and then it's got to
go right before the voters to make sure
it ends up on the ballot for the town
meetings and
um
I would much rather encourage local
schools to have money to set aside that
they can put into their Capital fund
that they can figure out whether this is
for a classroom Edition because they
need four more new classrooms and they
can start planning it or it's a major
I'm using the root the term roof repair
right they have a huge major Capital
project they've got to re-roof the whole
school system it's it's significant
expense those things can be taken care
of and this is One Way Concord can help
those local school Banks and final
question uh yep who are the agents to
expend
yeah the process so so the the money
um would be sent from the treasury
Department here to the local school
boards to be put into Capital funds and
then there's restrictions
um
apologize
[Music]
um
it would be on page
where is the
um
sorry
oh page one section three
um starting on line 23 right new
buildings editions major Renovations
major repairs lease space temporary
classrooms or adding to the capital
reserves right the money is not intended
to do the routine maintenance like
winter snow plowing and annual painting
and and Landscaping and those things
this is truly about taking and making
sure there's infrastructure there
necessary to support education so one
more uh I'm sorry too many questions
probably but who is is it the legit in
other words the legislative body that
you call a public hearing and and have
the legislative body decide who decides
what and and who is authorized to spend
that money actually that could my
understanding that could vary by talents
because different towns have different
thresholds on when they have to go to
their body for expending some towns or
sb2 towns right some are not some have
to manage ten thousand dollar projects
via a warrant article some don't if it's
put into the capital reserve the local
school board's going to know what they
can do in that town and not do because
if you give I and being on a school
board for 90 years they know that you if
you're the agents to expand usually you
can you hold a public hearing and and
then you explain the money the goal is
to get the money to the local school
board to allow them to make the
decisions on how to how best to take
care of their building so we don't have
to micromanage from Concord
what gets done
thank you Mr chair
thank you representative who for taking
my question I'm going to try and become
because I am so upset about this I can't
even begin to tell you okay
um first of all what I understand is you
are
first of all I just want to say on
behalf of the Department of Ed Amy does
a fabulous job in your comments about
that I found
very hurtful and totally incorrect but
going on so from what I'm understanding
this proposal would totally eliminate
building Aid as it is now we would take
the money that we have in the current
budget along with the 75 million dollars
that is in the governor's hp2 and you
would distribute this in that manner um
just one question with regard to the
distribution will that distribution go
to children who have the efas
that's that would be efas yes
representative efas are students who are
no longer in the public school system
all right thank you
um so
we have not had a public hearing school
districts don't know about this there's
some rumors out there
um Concord is here today
um they're here because they're hoping
that they would get into the yesterday
we were having the conversation about
can we add enough money so that we could
maybe get Concord in Litchfield um in in
the funding process this year now that
negates all of this all everything that
Amy has done all her work is gone it's
it's thrown out essentially isn't that
true
so um the current building projects okay
that are in queue
um Concord is asking for 70 million
dollars toward 176 million dollar Middle
School yes okay at 195 000 per child per
classroom it's right and I did speak
with Amy on this and it is I am not in
any way attacking Amy we had a
conversation okay the process is not
about a particular individual in the doe
the processes are statutes drive a very
long time between initial application
okay and approval by the voters and and
getting the bonds necessary to build a
building and that is a statutory issue
which is what we're here to address as
opposed to a Personnel issue okay yes
Concord is asking they want a new school
okay Litchfield also but if I compare
those are items number or whatever those
are applicants number four and number
five on the current building Aid list
Concord is asking for 70 million dollars
for 176 million dollar Middle School
okay for 900 students and
Litchfield is asking for if I recall 10
or 11 million dollars 12 million dollars
something like that for a 32 million
dollar Middle School 4ish 100 students I
don't have the exact number I did look
at both parts of both applications
um there's a huge disparity between
those two applications in terms of the
cost per child and and we do have rules
and statutes about how many square feet
is allowed in an application and how
many dollars per square foot is allowed
all of that's us in Concord trying to
tell local school systems how to design
their buildings I think that process is
flawed it's not about the individuals
who participate it's the process itself
that could use representative you
realize local municipalities have rules
with regard to how schools are built how
the process is
towns still will have to go to the
voters to get bonds towns will still
have to go through a variety of things
to get approval the hope of building Aid
and we have had a moratorium for 10
years 10 years it's been a moratorium
because of the tail
now without any understanding school
districts now are reapplying you have
not done any kind of a public hearing
you have not met with people there's
been no feedback and luckily there are
lots of people here today so maybe we
can hear from them if you don't mind Mr
chair but I just okay first of all I
have to say I promise you I will never
vote on a budget that has this never
okay
um with all due respect there was a
hearing on this concept scheduled
several weeks ago where we introduced it
for the first time I understand that
okay so let's not just say there was
never a public hearing on this okay
there was a public hearing
misrepresentative I don't want to argue
with you okay I just want you to know I
find this very disturbing
being a former assistant superintendent
actually working on a an addition to the
school at Dunbarton and the work that I
did with the Department was
extraordinarily helpful in terms of the
design of of the work that we did
um I don't know what I would have done
actually without them the same thing in
Goffstown same thing in New Boston
I just am very disturbed but I just let
me finish my say I just am very
disturbed by this proposal and I think
that
our local school districts
deserve better than this thank you okay
no more questions
yeah thank you Mr chair and good morning
good morning um a couple questions
um and I guess a comment uh first of all
I'm you know
um every Pro every process
at these kinds of levels with so much
money they're all there's always going
to be issues where it's fraud where we
could do better so I'm open to new ideas
um so you know this is I find it
interesting I'm not sure I find it
usable but I'm open to you know broader
discussion about how we might do this
better I don't find um I can just do my
three questions and maybe you can go
through there but if not I'll cycle back
um I don't find section three is it yeah
to be really sufficient in terms of the
restrictions on how the money is used so
I'm concerned about uh guard rails in
terms of misuse of this money and I
don't mean misuse in a nasty way but
just sort of a misunderstanding of it
sure I would be curious to see a
schedule of how this money would accrue
over time to see whether or not this
would be effective compared to the
current model my main concern is that we
don't know
um this isn't fleshed out enough in my
mind to know how this is going to play
out over time and I would be curious to
know you know this is the new model and
how this would play out this is the old
model this is what we're doing is there
any intersections between the two but I
just don't see how we can go forward
with this for me with not understanding
and not actually seeing how this will
actually look 10 years down the line how
long would it take for a school to
accrue enough money to do the project
they want to do
what happens if they haven't accrued the
money and there's an emergency that
comes up and they need to do something
now and you know because we I've done
away with this building Aid they're not
able to do that because they're still
accruing money there's a big gap between
what's now and what's later on so I have
real concerns about the transitions how
this intersects with local processes
that's another thing that I would need
to understand what's the difference
between the now and the future there's
just a big gap for me and I really do
like to spend time and I think a lot of
time generally because you know your
brain is working all the time and coming
up with um you know questions that you
didn't have before about any unforeseen
consequences of this and it's a new
project there will be unforeseen
consequences it'd be nice if we could
get most of those if we were good to go
in this direction and I'm at this point
I'm totally not comfortable doing this
because of these concerns so I just you
know to recap there's the restrictions
on the money of how that would be used I
see a lot of misuse I don't I would like
to see a schedule of you know this how
long would it take for a school to
accrue enough money you're talking about
sixty thousand dollars how long would it
take to get you know from that sixty
thousand dollars to a 32 million dollar
project if you need to rebuild the
school it doesn't seem to me that
there's even that that's possible
um so I'd like to see the schedules and
I'm concerned about
um again if you haven't accrued enough
money and you have a disaster they're
going to have to come to the state
anyway I think that's if there's an
emergency now I believe there are
mechanisms to fill that in so I'm open
to new ideas and New Concepts but um I
think this if if there's Merit here it
needs a little bit needs a lot more
study a lot more planning in terms of
how one might do this and um you didn't
answer the question I don't think about
the current projects in the queue
um do they just go away I think you we
kind of got off on another topic there
and so it sounds like this you know well
one two and three be funded or do they
get not funded because of this now which
I can't support and even schools that
are close to being ready to have a
project what happens to them does that
go away too and again those are things
that I can't support this with all those
unknowns
so um let me answer your three questions
I'll start with the third question first
right line six through ten talk about
building projects that were authorized
and funded already right prior to June
30th 2023 shall continue
this also funds the tail right for
obligations that we have had for Bond
payments to continue so the promise is
that Concord is made are ready to those
that have been approved continue that
one's an easy one taken care of in the
very beginning in terms of misuse
um under lines 24 through 27
um
I think Capital expenditures are pretty
clear most of the time local school
boards manage things at a capital level
things that go back to their capital
budget
this is not their annual operating
budget just like we have hb1 hb2 which
are a budget we also have a capital
projects under hb25 capital projects at
local school systems are treated
differently if you think that we need
tighter language than that I'm open to
suggestions in terms of total costs per
school system per child right this build
out this plan how many
you're gonna we need to look at a school
building over 50 years and then how much
does it cost to build a building that's
good for 50 years and how many students
right are in that classroom and then do
the math
um I think the number might be closer to
twice this when I do that level of math
right some of this is going to come from
the local school board some of this is
going to come from Concord but if you
theoretically put 20 students in a
classroom for 50 years
okay
um that's a thousand times whatever we
have here that we're putting toward that
classroom and the question is is if it's
300 is that enough times right
multiplying it by a thousand to cover
the cost of building that one classroom
for that period of time I think
when I do the math 100 is probably the
right number roughly speaking in terms
of ballpark cost per square foot
Amy might be a much better person right
she she spends her time doing this we
did have a couple conversations
we did also talk about Concord right and
if I follow the current statutory
requirements for Concord the ask was 70
million the statute caps it somewhere
between 28 and 30 million roughly
speaking because there's dollars so many
square feet are allowed so many dollars
per square foot we went through those
calculations together on the phone and
rough numbers I didn't do I didn't have
a calculator with me we're talking
roughly 30 million dollars half of what
they're asking for
um I don't know that it makes sense to
tell the voters in the town we're going
to do 176 million dollar project and
30 percent of that's going to come from
Concord when really it's only about 15
percent of that total projects coming
from Concord so I I want a transparency
that happens at the local level as well
and I
I think this is a great way the voters
can then count on this is how much we're
going to have available this year to
work on capital projects and Concord
routinely sorry Don Martin routinely has
put money aside for fire trucks and
capital reserve projects and and the
school and
the town dump everything puts money
aside because they know long term
they're going to need to do something to
do these major Capital expenditures
in terms of emergencies that's a great
question I don't have an answer for you
on that one and the reason I don't have
an answer is I didn't know about a
process where a town suddenly runs into
a major issue and comes back to Concord
and says we need this money now maybe
there is that process I'm not sure where
that is in the statute I'd have to look
at that
it's going forward but
by several um
sessions of if this happens this is what
it looks like if this would go this
direction this is what it looks like
instead of doing this I mean this is way
more than flipping a switch to make the
change I think it's a serious change
it's an up upheaval kind of a change
um and so I can't support you know I
would support studying this going
forward because you know maybe there's
Merit I'm fine to you know consider
alternatives but I'm not fine with
shutting the door now opening another
door and not knowing where that door is
going to go
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking questions
um let me start by saying that I'm
trying to understand the intent behind
your proposal right and what I hear and
please correct me if I'm wrong is that
you are looking at the current process
and you feel that it's not really
Equitable that some schools get help
others don't and you are looking to
basically spread the wealth equally or
per student in terms of
you know financing every student in the
state equally in terms of building Aid
is that the intent of this
public school students right every
public school student is to make sure
that they have access to a classroom
correct okay
um if I just if I can jump please I have
it I'm double booked at triple books if
I'm in here as well at 10 30. so I have
a little bit of a hard cut off at 10 30.
fully understood
um you already answered the question I
was going to ask about the emergency
repairs basically by saying that you
don't know about process and actually I
would love to hear from the committee
members or anybody else in the room if
at this time if a school has a you know
boiler breaks down and they need a
hundred thousand to repair it and they
don't have the funds if there is any
state process that you know we would
want to preserve I'm not aware of any
but maybe I don't know about it and um
right now we are
using building Aid not to fully pay for
a school at the end of the day this is
Aid it's a portion of the financing
right so I I would
some of the models that we were asking
earlier were you know can all this money
pay for a classroom in 50 years well it
needs to pay for a portion of the
classroom the town still has to you know
contribute to that so I would appreciate
it if any modeling and Analysis would be
on that basis just looking at how much
we you know can help
so I I think that while there are a lot
of questions about how do we handle the
transition you know this this is an idea
that you know may have married
one quick question though and that's my
last question
you are saying projects approved to you
know prior to June 30 2023 yes I mean at
this point in time we should be pretty
close to knowing because we have the
warrant articles right so we know who
got approved and who is not and probably
the Department of Education could give
us an idea of who they think this is
just the three that have been approved
right as representative Heath said
Concord is currently number four on the
list they have not been approved and
number five is Litchfield that they have
not been do you know if these those two
towns had a warrant article this spring
no I don't believe they've been approved
from the state side okay so they would
need that approval okay I'm good thank
you so much
one question yes in addition to actually
uh Capital Improvements could These
funds be used to pay for debt for
Capital Improvements
could I take my annual payments and pay
off the loan I took to build the
building
hmm
it's a great question I don't know that
that would be in the current guard rails
but if this committee thought that that
was a wise idea to help start paying
down local debt as in addition I think
that could easily be put in line 24
right foreign even incurring long-term
debt if this could be yes that's what I
mean if it was available that would be
an e right that would be an easy change
I
can you weigh in yeah so if you wanted
to add debt service for Capital or
Capital Debt Service payments to section
Roman 3 online 24 it could easily be
none yeah
that might be a wise way to help local
facil right local towns take care of
some of their existing Debt Service or
new Debt Service yes
well what you say you can use it for
Debt Service oh yeah sure yeah okay
somebody didn't mean
if you use it for the debt surface that
kind of defeats the purpose of using
money for building Aid to me it would be
not allowed for Debt Service
my understanding is
this is to help offset the cost of the
communities what what this approach does
is you you're going to get x amount of
dollars
every year
how big what do you want to do you can
build a new school with it if you want
to here's what it's going to be budget
yourself accordingly
but then we're still talking about how
that money can be used and again I think
this is part of the modeling what I
would like to see
um and you reminded me of another
question
um I don't know if I'm comfortable with
it using for Debt Service because this
is supposed to be building Aid going
forward so I'm confused about that and
then the other question which just I can
just throw it out is you know it's
another thing to consider
um
one of the considerations is temporary
classrooms which is very different than
a major renovation major repairs these
are just such different buckets in terms
of what you do with the school building
or the school campus that again I'm just
uncomfortable
it's it's
I'm not having a good sense of what this
um
what the outcomes would be for some of
these things I don't think and you know
maybe you can talk to that later on we
hear from doe is there building a to put
in temporary classrooms now this is a
different ball of wax it seems so it's
just there's
crisscrossing uh the lines are not
cleared
I know hacking haken is it hicken
Phillips or Hackett hackenfels I said it
okay hacken Phillips had a question so I
want to make sure I get a chance to
answer her question she had her hand up
a couple times let me answer that one if
I can okay and then
you have a question thank you Mr Sharon
thank you for taking my question so um
to not recreate any of the concerns
already previously brought although I I
must admit I do share concern
um
furthermore I apologize I'm Switching
gears quickly I just came from Joel car
and
um I am just reading this for the first
time I'm I'm not sure if everyone else
is but so I feel a little bit of
um
like urgency to express my questions in
a way that's
um helpful and I too am interested in
discussing the future of school building
Aid and and oh you know being open to
suggestions for doing it more
appropriately more equitably you know
I'm open to finding a better solution
moving forward because I know this is a
chronic problem for our state so with
that in mind
um
you know I I think I'm mostly concerned
with the premise that I believe you've
stated a few times that I want to make
sure I'm correct I'm I'm getting this
correctly that you're trying to with
this bill to simplify a cost allocation
per child per square footage
for our districts is that that is
correct
so I think that premise to begin with
just for the record is probably
problematic I think we all know that
funding school buildings across the
state is not the same value per student
per square foot you know real estate
values differ across the state as well
as square footage within each of these
public school buildings or Char school
school buildings um per square foot you
know for the instance the cost to build
a large gymnasium is much different than
the cost to build you know a special
education room or
um you know disability
um
Corridor so I think we have to just step
back from that premise to begin with and
say
we understand that this is a complex
issue that has been
part of our state struggle for a long
time and that you know to simplify
per cost per child across the states
maybe not sufficient for what we're
trying to accomplish and I I think it's
an interesting idea I'm not trying to
poo poo it but I think we need to
be pragmatic about our expectations
for addressing this real concern
um and then I want to say you know just
a quick cursory review of you know a
couple sections I'm looking at page two
line 10 you know the minimum
Appropriations for the biennium I think
it is acknowledged here in our committee
that 50 million dollars for school
building Aid in each of the next two
years is has proven to be insufficient
and that we are trying to work on
finding solutions to
um you know address these ongoing cues
of schools who are asking for much more
than that but also to consider you know
what can our state do moving forward
um at a at a level that will actually
solve the problem so how can we strive
to meeting that need which is clearly
insufficient at this amount
um do you have a question for
representative yeah so you know I'm also
looking you know I'm also looking at
page two line 23 this section you know
there's
this fun being set up
um through the treasury and it shall be
used you know you identify the purpose
here but I'm not seeing an explanation
about the rules or promises or processes
that would be put in place for
distribution have you thought through
that more adequately I think the
question earlier was is this up to local
school districts and how would they
distribute it but I never actually heard
a follow-up to you know the complete
answer to that that question okay so I'm
out of time but I will do my best to
answer it quickly right which is the
state treasury will be sending the money
to the local school board to be put into
a capital reserve fund and then the
local school board will be tasked with
how that that capital reserve fund or
Capital project is is then addressed and
the goal here is to move and to
decentralize control of how building Aid
happens from Concord being the one
that's picking winners and losers
amongst the various school districts
because we haven't funded every project
for a very long time and we don't have
the money necessary to completely fund
the entire list to helping all the
schools in the state
yes it is a little bit of a transition
is definitely somewhat of a paradigm
shift but I think in the end it yields
much better result because local control
yields better results for the towns
involved
I would love to take more questions I
can come back but I'm definitely double
booked okay thank you yep
um for the record Mr chair I don't think
there was an answer to the question
about the distribution process that was
addressed other than saying that it's
local control but again I think we need
to be able to identify what kind of
distribution requirements would be you
know at the local level that we're
talking about so I just I think there's
a lot of glaring holes
um specifically with that funding
distribution
point in that section
yeah
if I may offer an opinion in regards to
uh you know the question just asked
if I understand correctly right now any
money allocated by state for building
Aid has can only be spent based on a
warrant authorized by Town voters right
they have to pass a warrant to receive
building a
I would have no problem if we decide to
go in this direction as a policy putting
a similar requirement that any money in
that capital reserve account can only be
expanded upon the authorization of the
Town voters at you know March
but that's just my you know quick
thought on that
all right thank you Mr chair
um I'm a trustee of the trust funds I
also been on a school board uh the way I
think I think this should go on is have
the legislative body have a vote
a public hearing a vote and then uh not
make the school the agent uh the agents
to expand can be the school board but
after a public hearing and a legislative
body vote
I mean that
that's the way it works a lot but we see
warrants all the time uh you know for
say a fire truck is the uh the selectman
the uh agents to expend or or whoever
and that or it could be the fire chief
and in case of motorbike motor you know
like fire trucks so the bait the big
thing is the public hearing legislative
body approval and then the school
board's agent to accept
and once I like to make comments please
thanks Nikki
there are enough copies there for the
public as well
no that's another one that has to go
around
that you want it three-hole you might
want to punch it for you
well good morning again uh chairman and
members of the division two uh for the
record my name is Rick Ladd I chair
House Education
um
and I come from Haverhill New Hampshire
I'm here today to really communicate
with you that I have
a great deal of concern regarding this
bill I'm not saying I'm I I'm totally
against it but I have a lot of concern
regarding process here
when I came to the hearing when this was
discussed here under hb2 there was no
identification in the hearing process
that school building Aid was I was kind
of shocked myself after we left a noon
time that something was done that I
didn't see it so I didn't know you and I
understand the process hb2 you have so
many components it's very difficult you
can't put that all on the calendar but
let me tell you that during the hearings
which we've had in education we've had
four bills on school building Aid this
year and it's it's taken days to get
through some of that and the testimony
that we're hearing from the public so
what I have here are three sheets for
you and the first one I'd like to look
at right here is this one right here
I put that uh quickly together last
night when I was watching Penn State
beat Texas A M and I'm an Aggie
and so at any rate
um that's behind me
so at any rate what I want to do is try
to do a comparison between what we have
in current law right now
and what this is trying to do
to maybe what I'll do first is there
were several questions which were asked
what about emergency aid well Haverhill
Middle School had the roof go bad about
seven years ago totally gone
and it was an emergency it had to be
repaired we were able to obtain
emergency funds from the state to repair
that building it's in statute we had to
take the kids for one year and put them
in the Armory while we had that roof
totally removed it's a huge Middle
School
another issue which I'd like to talk
about is this moratorium we've just come
through with the tail
in another couple years we're going to
be beyond the major payments on that
tail so we're going to have more of that
50 million dollars available for use of
this and uh I think that's a very
important aspect which we need to
remember the we have a backlog of
buildings needs in this state now as a
direct result of the moratorium and
we've got to somehow get ahead of that
so in looking at this right here I took
a hypothetical building and the average
cost of an elementary school is around
7.7 million dollars
and you can see if you follow through on
this sheet
and for an elementary student it costs
about 295 dollars per square foot per
pupil
and an elementary student needs
approximately somewhere between 55 and
70 square feet
in that facility
so if you take a 62 square feet as kind
of the middle between the 55 and the 70
and multiply that times 400 students
which would fit into that building
Elementary wise that would be 24.8
000 square feet needed in that facility
at 295 dollars per pupil you can see
that comes out roughly around 7.3
million dollars so it's close to that
7.7 as the as the average
under this formula
we would be appropriating for an
elementary student 300 per year
multiplied times number of students Etc
in that District
for a school a size the one I'm talking
about let's say you have a small
Elementary District with 400 that's not
really small in our state because we
have some that are 67 kids 50 kids but
I'm taking 400 kids
400 times 300 is 1 120 000 dollars
now let's go down below and compare it
to where and how we do it now compared
to what this is proposing
under the current formula
if a district was one that had a little
bit more wealth than the others you'd
get 30 percent of the cost that building
if the building is 7.7 million dollars
that means you would have received from
the state 2 million three hundred and
ten thousand dollars
80 percent of it's up front 20 percent
upon completion
under this proposal hb2 you would
receive 300 per student per year and it
would take 19.25 years for you to accrue
2 million three hundred and ten thousand
dollars
now let's go up the ladder a little bit
from 30 percent to 60 percent those are
the communities which really are in need
in this state there are poorer
communities they don't have the dollars
to build the castle that we'd like to
see for our kids
so at sixty percent under that formula
we have right now in the books they
would receive for their Grant four
million six hundred twenty thousand
dollars of that 7.7
from the state 80 percent up front 20
percent upon completion under this
proposal hb2 at 300 per pupil per year
it would take 38.5 years for that
District to have the money to build that
building
that is not helping our poorer
communities we have in this state that's
a real fallacy in this bill
now last night before I left here late I
asked our researcher here to do some
research for us there's two states have
a similar type funding formula at least
on a per pupil basis each year Kentucky
and Virginia
but then you start delving down into the
mechanics of that formula and it gets to
a lot of criteria such as property
valuation in regions of the locations in
the state demographics it gets into
property wealth uh property uh poor
towns Etc it gets in those Dynamics and
the parts that in the fact even in some
of the one of those states there is no
building aid for the very very wealthy
community
so what we've got to do is before we
step off the deep edge here and and and
put a policy in place let's go through
the process and do it correctly
now we've had just heard and I've also I
gave to Mickey here two other bills
which we had here we just finished
correcting the school building Aid uh
formula we have now with a timeline that
works so the the districts know before
well before now their their town meeting
when they're going to have to have a
warrant put forth what they're going to
do and they can they can take to that
warrant on the condition that we get
this you're going to vote Yes or no
so um on this sheet I still don't want
to depart from it because I I'm trying
to rush so others have an opportunity
here there are a number of issues which
we have to resolve and we have held one
of our bill bills back in house
education specifically to address what
you're trying to address right here
we're trying to address all those issues
associated with school building a and
here's a couple of the items is there a
way to fund smaller projects alongside
larger ones I'm also the chair of the
public school infrastructure Commission
and we've had over 40.3 million dollars
some of us go for some it's been
appropriated by the state uh
representative Heats on that on that and
representative hill behind me is on that
could this be a way to fund some of
those smaller projects we're talking
about renovation in the future could
there be a different pot of money I
don't know but it's a thought and it's
something we ought to be considering
how do Charters fit into the process we
discussed that thoroughly within our
house education committee and there are
a number of issues which have to be uh
discussed what happens if a charter goes
out of business
and they've received a grant who has to
pay that within statute it right now it
says the resident School District
captures that well our Charter has kids
come through many many districts
so there that's part of the cleanup we
have to do even when Charter School law
we have to do a cleanup and to ensure
that the whole process is workable going
to the flip side and the back side some
of the issues that we're looking at
emergency projects there has to be a way
to Fund emergency projects we have it in
statute right now we work with Amy Clark
at the department we want an issue like
this and this is stuff that's not just I
think I have an emergency process it's
built in conjunction with school
building code and fire code and it has
to be identified by the State Fire
Marshal as an emergency project
should building Aid pay for Career
Technical education
the kohlberg project has some CTE in it
and we are asking well we have another
pot for a CTE programs
which is over the light you know and
it's based upon when a CTE went into
business and that and then we go through
the other 25 and it rotates around
unfortunately that's not really working
right either so by the time it comes
around again your your diesel mechanics
is so obsolete that you're you're having
to really upgrade the whole thing do
security and safety issues uh need to
rise to the top of the Heat
we're looking at that right now too and
yes we do have a Proviso in the law
right now where if you receive so many
points in the area of safety it does go
ahead of some of the other projects
should pre presidents be provided in all
projects that already applied that have
been ranked so the next year other
projects come in do they go on top of
what's already been ranked we have 17
projects now three of which we're we're
on on the list uh for approving and the
dollars which receive in that are not
yet the dollars which uh the the state
will decide There's issues still they're
looking at the standards to make sure
what the district's asking for
agrees or aligns with what the standards
are and by the way if you hand this
money out in this 300 method it's still
State dollars you're going to still have
to build those buildings because you're
using State Appropriations in
conformance with the law that we have
that the standards have to be filed
we've had districts before have gone
ahead and built and not built the square
footage required in the classroom and
had to rebuild
we don't want to go there and I'm not
going to say the name of that District
but it was within the last several years
should charitable trust bequest gifts
insurance policies
be subtracted from the state Grant
right now they are
and yet we have one project up in
Colebrook which has just been approved
where they have had a benefactor come
forward and say I have two million
dollars I'll help you with your project
but that won't subtract from the state
aid that we presently have in law one of
the bills I gave you right here accounts
for that and corrects that that will be
coming to the house in 452.
in regard to new construction offset
State share a building Grant by sale of
any assets that's a problem we have
if you have a new facility going in on a
different location do the assets come
from the old property the old facility
go against the the state share or maybe
the district's using that for adult
vocational education or as a career tech
center or as a charter school so we've
got to look at there's a lot of Dynamics
with that equation too
and I think that would be inappropriate
to ask even with concord
study methods of ensuring long-term
sustainability funding for school
buildings and identify sources of such
funds that has to be done where the
money's coming from which pot of money
should State share of Grant be flat
funded consider Community wealth income
levels grades in schools geographic
location demographics that's partially
what you're trying to do here but we
haven't considered all that other yet
should 80 percent be provided
immediately looking at our own formula
right now should that be up front or
should we give a lesser amount and
spread the wealth a little bit more to a
few other projects that's to be
considered should be 50 50. we've looked
at that and that has to be and we will
be looking all these issues in the next
by November of this year we have a study
group that's going to be set up based
upon the bill we retained
access eligibility criteria what are the
criteria that we use to rank order all
these that has to be looked at too we
have now high performance schools with
Energy Efficiency we have schools that
would like to consolidate and and go
from three buildings maybe to two
buildings saving administrative costs
and all that that's a consideration
really should be and that's what they
were looking for in the state of Vermont
when they went ahead with their act over
there and that's what Maine went into
when they tried to consolidate all the
sads over there and they only had one
one District bite on that and that was
Rumford Mexico
I mentioned that Kentucky and Virginia
there I have researchers right now
researching this with the education
Commission of the states that
information will be coming back to us
this is part of the communications we're
getting back from ECS there are a number
of ways to fund schools we have not
considered all those and we really
should
and also as you may recall several years
ago we put forward building a bill
wanting to have a Statewide condition
assessment that would have cost at that
time 3.3 million dollars for us to have
teams go out and analyze every facility
with an architect engineer policy people
so then we can project our 10-year plan
what's it really look like what do we
have for needs out there where are we
going to put our dollars
3.3 million dollars you can talk to Amy
when she comes up here it'd probably be
higher now but it's it's a process that
should be used Montana uses it and they
have similar populations we have and
they found that that's able to save on
building eight if you know what you get
and you know what you compare you're
going to have to pay out in another 10
years or down the line
so the other two sheets I'll quickly
reference are are there was one
Amendment which we did not
um uh go ahead and you'll notice that
there was a committee which we were also
looking at to put in HB 452 which would
require the committee study right now
but we felt we could do it by holding a
bill get on the task immediately rather
than waiting for a bill to have to be
signed in by the governor
and so with that we we are already on
track for doing exactly what you're
doing but I encourage you
please do not move forward with a bill
that has not received if you're going to
deal with something overhauling our
entire School building aid process make
sure that's properly heard make sure you
have these superintendents like
superintendent Taylor up in Colebrook
who came and testified the other week
with us and told us I can't use this
charitable money to help me with the
State Building then I'm trying to cut
the cost down of the state
so so uh please consider that it's it's
a it's one of the areas funding
methodologies we need to pursue I agree
with you but it's not been thoroughly
vetted and there's a lot more look at
Kentucky look at Virginia and see what
they did with this formula it's a lot
deeper than this week put on two or
three pages here that that's that's too
quick a way to try to resolve we're
we're trying to get over to the end too
fast and too quick I'm afraid we're
going to get down that rabbit hole and
have to really try to climb out of it
when we find it doesn't really work and
I'd also be concerned about some of
these schools which you're approving
right now the three possibly four
because if there are additional dollars
left over and some might go to uh
Concord are we going to fund them in
subsequent years that 20 later on or in
based upon the new formula or the
formula we have right now
a lot of consideration thank you very
much Mr chairman
thank you with your Indulgence I have
two or three questions if I made really
quickly so
just to start you know by addressing the
very last point that representative
blood was mentioning I think the bill
clearly says that the projects were
approved by June 2023 will go ahead you
know under the current rules and
legislation so that they go ahead but my
concern is after you pay that 80 then
you're into another program how's the 20
can be funded I I would argue that the
current bill language says that the the
process for the current applications
that are approved by then will be
unchanged and this only talks about
future building a but of course language
can you know be checked right so one
question that I had for you
um you were talking about the fact that
um
it will take up to 38.5 years for a
school to get the equivalent you know
for a school district to get the
equivalent amount of money they get up
front right now that's an approximation
there's no interest we're all talking
ballpark numbers right
given that the expected life of a school
building is longer than that I'm trying
to understand why do you feel that's not
sufficient in the long term I'm not
asking about the current short-term
disruptions if we would move in a
direction like this but
it seems that we would be giving them
more over time because right now they
would get eight every you know 50 years
on when they replace a school building
while now they would get it you know
about every 40 years at the worst case
scenario so I'm trying to understand
what the concern is with that duration
well that's just one building within a
school district so you're going to be
funding all those schools because uh
there's a number of schools that are
over a hundred years old
um are is there going to be some kind of
a priority as to what we hit here uh if
everybody's going to be handed out equal
amounts right now
um that that brings up a whole lot of
other questions I appreciate that really
helps me understand what your concerns
are thank you and um
we were talking about the um
roof emergency that you were mentioning
from middle school do you know since
you've been through that whether the
funds that we got through the states
were from the building Aid or they were
from a different general fund or a
different source
it's written underneath the building Aid
section that chapter of law that there
is an emergency process if it's
recommended and the commissioner has May
waive and move forward with that now you
can ask Amy where are the specific
dollars come from but I believe it's we
have several pots even the pot for
catastrophic Aid as well in special
education I got you thank you I
appreciate it and the very last quick
question
um you were talking about the charitable
trusts and donations I'm just going to
refer to this as donations it is my
understanding that you said that right
now if the School receives donations
that would be taken out of the school
building Aid if it were three million
dollars the state had and it got two
your state will only pray one and is
this a policy you support or would you
like to see that change I support well
you'll see it's already in one of the
bills there we're taking that out
charitable gifts insurance policy all
that and leaving now we agree that if
there's another source of Revenue coming
from the state or federal government
that will come out of the you know the
uh the three million dollars if that two
million dollars was coming from another
state Grant or a Federal grant that two
million dollars would be taken out that
was a unanimous vote 20-0 within the
education committee so your policy
proposal would include
essentially taking whatever donations
could get out of this process that's in
this one right here it's in uh zero one
zero one seven eight to four five two
that will be coming to the house floor I
appreciate it thank you sir
thank you Mr chairman
so the the school building aid program
is a state aid program that intends to
help out the local local municipalities
or the school districts
and that's why that's why it gets it
gets funded in in
um
more of a
more of a um
more or all at once rather than
what this thing what this bill proposes
is is it sounds more like operational
income we we used to not fund it like
this we used to fund over the life of
the of the bond the state did that but
what we did it must have been back 2012
11. 11. that we changed to put 80 up
front that saves the interest on the
part of the town so it helps the towns
out and that was our primary goal there
thank you one follow-up even before that
and when it used to pay
um a percentage of the finance costs
that that was intended for capital
projects and that's where it went
what this what I see in this in this
proposal here is
300 I don't know three hundred dollars
three hundred dollars
per student comes out of the adequacy
money and goes to the school district
it's it's it's it's more like
operational revenue and it's it's
this this pot is sooner or later
somebody's going to grab that for
something else
that's a possibility unless you you know
indicate it such it can't be changed but
we did we have used those monies which
have been School building when we went
that 540 million dollars down the you
know the tube when we had the tail that
created we were funding everything but
monies can be used to offset your debt
service if it's related to the school
building a Cusco Capital Construction
program there's no problem with that and
you've had a little discussion on that
today and that's a worthy thing to do
that you're going to save money in the
district by paying off your debt uh so
but
um I'm just concerned about the process
you're following here it's a giant leap
which I I feel that we definitely need
more hearing on
thank you
yeah thank you for I'm sorry go ahead
Joe no go ahead you sure oh thank you
thank you Joe and thanks for doing this
this certainly addresses a lot of the
things that have been swirling around in
my head and if you just forgive me for
overstating what is probably obvious and
exaggerated
um if you're looking you know in your
chart here uh with the 38 and a half
years potentially the children of the
children in the school would be the ones
who benefit from this program the way it
is several children who are in the
school yes so thank you thank you well
yeah I thank Texas Aggies because they
were losing and I wasn't watching
yeah
thank you Mr chairman uh you mentioned
that uh you replaced a roof and it was
an emergency situation uh you didn't
have anything in your capital reserve I
mean and and let me before you answer
let me explain uh Farmington all right
he's a poor school which you always uh
help us out on
but we put money aside for roofs matter
of fact all the roofs have been recently
uh
renewed uh made up to Snuff the
buildings are in pretty good shape one
was built in 1950
uh the other two 95 and roughly in the
2000s and you know in a very they're
very serviceable and that's one thing we
our operational we we keep we keep our
buildings up to Snuff they are in very
good shape we have a gym we have uh two
gymnasiums that we take one which we
have an ironic situation because one is
owned by the town but it's part of the
school but nobody let's not say that but
that was a charitable gift also and the
high school
we had a five and a half million dollar
cost to build a high school a donor gave
two million dollars towards that and you
know and we we got to build hey it uh
it's very serviceable but you know if
you maintain your buildings your
buildings were lost a whole lot longer I
I agree with you and that's why several
years back when we were looking at
school building Aid we require any
project that is one million dollars or
more to have a clerk of the works that's
bonded not just your custodian in the
building unfortunately when they put the
middle school together back in the early
90s in Haverhill New Hampshire
the clerk of the works was the custodian
and change orders came through and ever
left and right
within our budgets maintenance is a
operational
responsibility of the school district
and we also put in our budget
maintenance money but when we have a
total roof structurally that wasn't
built properly that had the Kiln benting
up and into the attic and rotting out
everything up there and then going down
everything holding that roof up we had
to go well beyond a million dollars
that's why we put in effect anytime now
that there's something that go where
you're looking for State money that's
above a million bucks you must have a
bonded engineer overseeing that project
that's in statute
I just want to issue an apology I was
way out of line in my comments to the
representative who and um I will
apologize to him as well I clearly took
this way too personally I'm sorry
thank you
anything further chair no I I just
wanted to I appreciate your thoughts and
the the one variable that this hasn't
didn't address was the question I asked
about
could this pay debt Debt Service
and I have a question in that topic for
Mickey or anybody that knows under the
governor in the government accounting
definitions
do do it capital projects capital
expenditure are they defined
I can tell you can easily legislate that
debt service on Capital you know bonds
can be a permissible use of these funds
as far as a technical question like that
I see Mr Dunn in the room he would be an
expert from the district level to answer
questions like that I would defer to him
okay thank you
one more
Just One Last Question
um
I was asking representative Howell about
the intent of this process and you know
it was about the equity right where
right now there are so many school
districts that do not get building Aid
and they will never qualify for a
building Aid under the current process
because it's too cumbersome and just
impossible to navigate on unreasonably
hard to navigate will any of these
policy proposals that you are talking
about
make that system more fair and you know
because right now we kind of have a
system of haves and have-nots in terms
of building a
I I don't know if it's necessarily haves
and have-nots it's we had some districts
were very sharp and got on the stick
right after this moratorium and got
their applications in uh we had I don't
know Amy maybe about six or seven which
we've uh approved since that time Romney
got it seeing that they didn't have any
access to the second floor of the
building and handicapped parents
handicapped kids in a wheelchair
couldn't access the second floor they
couldn't get in the building the same
thing occurred in in other locations
so those were small districts that had
median family incomes which are low even
though Romney's right outside of
Plymouth uh I I don't know if that
that's it I think it's more result of
the 10 year moratorium we just came
through and we piled up all these
applications and needs and now we're
paying the piper for it and we had a
bill which I even I think it must have
come through here where in in
appropriating the dollars or building
Aid we were requesting that 50 million
dollars be appropriated for new or or
renovation Construction in each year on
top of the debt so the debt right now
the tail we talked about roughly 25
million dollars for the two years we're
looking at and and so we're using about
49 or 50 million dollars for those three
projects maybe a little less than maybe
some lap over into a project down below
so if we continue to do with that
process within several years when that
tail is low we're going to be seeing 75
million dollars each year for new
construction and renovation I think
we're just on the edge of going into an
era where we will have the funds I'd
love to see more money for new
construction renovation I don't think
we've ever funded it properly I even
tried at one point in time to have it
become part of adequacy
but it's not a part of adequacy and
that's why
um the the various cases we've had come
Londonderry Claremont they never went
after building a because at that time we
had it in separate pot and we were
funding building a I I appreciate it I I
just need to say that you know I agree
that the moratorium created difficulties
but that's what happens when the state
spends money they don't have you've got
to pay the piper so I would uh urge
future legislatures to never engage in
that type from your Visa card with your
MasterCard that's the deal
right then uh to follow up on that I it
kind of stole my thunder
I was going to ask you what is your
opinion why we have a moratorium and
that's pretty much was answered in the
last couple of seconds we were trying to
pay off that huge debt right that's a
simple one 540 million dollars
well we at that time we were trying to
sell uh state land because uh the budget
was so out of balance and we'll have
that all done in year 2041.
wow thank you oh I have a question for
Mickey if you will uh that 50 million in
the uh
representative Hallsville is that per
year in addition to
the regular 50 million
so what this amendment would do is
appropriate 50 million a year for the
new grant program
so yes for that
it maintains the tail payments and the
payments on the bonds that we have for
the the projects prior to approved and
funded prior to June 30 2023 but the
amount that's in the governor's budget
for new projects the 48 million or so
that representative ladgis referred to
would essentially be reduced and just
would remain in the education trust fund
so the amount in the governor's budget
for new projects would come out and be
offset with 50 million dollars a year
for the representative whole Amendment
like
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and committee I'll
just make a couple comments about the
hb2 amendment that was mentioned earlier
for you to think about my name is Jack
Dunn d-u-n-n I am the business
administrator for the Concord School
District
um
one of the concerns I would have with
the per pupil just an initially hearing
this would be how Bond counsel would
feel about it as it related to the
steadiness of that Revenue
in school districts in trying to borrow
money they would see that large sum of
money they have to look at their total
valuation and they only get a percentage
of that for debt so for example for
Concord we're about a four and a half
billion dollars for the Concord School
District portion of the city because we
have two school districts so if five
percent of that it's about 225 million
that's available for us to borrow
okay take out your existing debt which
is about 40 million now you're down into
the about 170s 180s if we have to borrow
all that because we have to make a
payment year of I'm estimating quickly
we get under that program about 1.29
million a year if it was 300 per student
K to 8 and 350 for high school I think
is what the representative mentioned so
that kind of debt that you would have
available now again this is only for one
school that we're looking at in Concord
we have other schools that are aging
hence why we did the three elementary
schools back in 2009 because we looked
at generations of students that were
just going to be under Perpetual
construction and that's what we were
concerned about and that's why we took
advantage of the program before the
moratorium but that would be my concern
by creating an annual fee
because this is also subject to
appropriation every two years they're
going to look at that as risk that if
you're dependent on that to make your
debt service payments
that is going to increase your interest
rates that they're going to charge when
Bond Council evaluates that Bond and
when an investor buys that so that would
be the concern I think maybe a hybrid of
having something like that but also Alum
sum is not a bad idea to look at but um
that would be probably my biggest
concern
um about the reducing and available debt
so that was the only comment I had
thank you Mr chairman so in Concord the
three school buildings that you had
surplused yeah did anyone value them
yep we had them valued and unsold them
yep so what we did in Concord is we had
three task force one before the
consolidation happened because we went
from nine elementaries to five and we
did that because you were getting down
to where you only had one classroom the
Eastman School for example only had 97
kids
10 15 years earlier it had 280 kids it
made no sense because you're also
helping pay for those buildings as a
state and local taxpayer so
what we did is we Consolidated from nine
down to five and built three new ones
with the old schools
of the three task force first was
educational second was what to do
um with the buildings that we needed to
build whether it was newer renovate and
the third was what are we going to do
with those buildings because the biggest
thing we didn't want was those buildings
closed we wanted them the active reuse
right away we wanted them primarily on
the tax rolls if we could and get them
sold so we had them all valued The
Walker School which was rebuilt in 1918
the original School burnt down that was
sold for 980 000 and that money was put
into a capital reserve the board was
disciplined enough to put it away and
say that's for future building project
hence is Project number four on your
list so we put that money away then you
had the Rumford school that was built in
1902 that building was sold to a private
investor and he's used for non-profits
so that is on the tax rolls as well as
The Walker School on the tax rolls that
sold for about 450 000 and that money
again put into a capital reserve
the Eastman School built in 1878 burnt
down rebuilt 1938. that was sold in I'm
sorry that we still own and as soon as
we moved out boys and glove Boys and
Girls Club moved in and they rent that
building in service the children in the
capital region area and then the Dame
school which was built in 1936 we didn't
feel that they the valuation of the city
of Concord School District portions
about 400 4.5 billion the value on the
pentacle side is about maybe 500 million
even though the Concord School District
portion of the taxpayers paid for that
school we didn't want to double tax the
city of Concord residents we sold that
building to them for one dollar
and in return if they ever try to sell
it it reverts back to the school
district so nobody's going to gain on
anybody but the reason why is they
wanted to build a community center on
that side of the river and we didn't
want to see taking several hundred
thousand dollars in taxpayer money from
the city residents to give it to the
school district whose residents also pay
school tax uh because we felt that that
could move that project along further
within a year of Us closing our schools
all the buildings were an active reuse
were on the tax rolls and that was the
goal I'm glad you came in it's a
different story than what we heard from
the
um
the other
or I guess it was the
person ahead of the school
said you gave away to and sold one and I
thought why are you giving it away when
you need the asset yeah and we Dame we
felt was different because it was our
sister government the city of Concord
did you know we are autonomous school
board so we are separate from the city
but we work very well together because
we all have the same people paying the
bill I think that was the superintendent
that gave us that testimony we gave two
away and I thought then you're asking us
for more money when that represents
money that you gave away no but your
testimony is quite different and I think
you were the one that was working on it
thank you you're welcome
right thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here thanks uh
what's the equalized evaluation of
Concord if you know
equalized valuation right four four and
a half billion four and a half billion
but for the city of concord's school
district portion yes right but all of
the city I don't know what that is I'm
going to say it's close to five because
then you gotta count the Merrimack
Valley School District and
is that under the Concord Banner it's
under city of Concord so when we get the
ms-1 we get our portion and then
Merrimack gets their portion
thank you
thank you thank you and
non-government accounting is called
fasby
in the government is Gatsby is Gatsby
like Fast be have definitions of what
capital in capital projects Capital
Investments are yes okay thank you
you're welcome
okay very helpful you're welcome
anyone else would like to comment
please
so again for the record my name is Amy
Clark and I'm with the Department of
Education in the school building aid
program falls under my Bureau so I guess
I would just want to clarify a couple of
things I mean I have tons of notes
um so this is the first time I've seen
this amendment so it's hard to like
really digest it
um I just went through the club right uh
so I think that my my short my somewhat
long list of questions could probably
grow into a couple pages of questions uh
after reading it through but
um just a couple of things the way I
read it again just sitting in my seat
just now
um
to be clear the department of education
does not have that list of 17 projects
that you um that we're referring to
those projects are not approved by the
department those are ranked by the
department they don't become approved
until other things happen uh Warren
articles have passed
um they're under a contract with their
contractor and they're ready to go so in
this the line seven it talks about
uh that this would everybody prior to
June 30th 2023 that's approved that is
not going to include any of the projects
on the list of 17. so I just want to
clarify that that doesn't fund
any the way I read it doesn't fund any
of the schools on that list
quick question if I may think Mr
chairman and sorry for you know jumping
in but
I hear what you are saying that
technically the word approved does not
apply to the ones that we refer to as a
proof because they still have to go
through the propyl Hoops say that the
sponsor or the uh proposed legislation
would be whether men that date to 2024
you know June 30 2024 with that in
effect result in you know the projects
that we're gonna you know finalize being
approved if you know being eligible for
the state aid so would they be approved
you know if they go through the warrant
with the approval application for
whichever project should be eligible be
complete by June 30 2024.
um so if that date was changed to 2024
the way I think we would interpret it
would be if money was appropriated we
would start at the top of the list and
work down through so we'd offer that
money until we ran out
um if you made it to 2025 then we would
do that for year one of the biennium and
again for year two of the biennium which
would be an affect the way the law is
right now thank you
uh so I wanted to point that out that um
that I thought that that was um
something to
um and I love I love when people do math
problems because it gets us Engineers
excited
um and um
um love that um representative Vlad made
an attempt but I I think that he was
watching the a game at the time so I'm
gonna uh um give him partial credit
um I hope he forgives me for that
um but the I think I don't have his hand
out in front of me but I think I heard
him say 50 square feet per pupil perhaps
um I think he might be talking about
classroom space so when you look at
square footage for a building that's
probably somewhat accurate per pupil for
classroom space but of course the school
building is not classroom space
um cafeteria space gym space we actually
have a term we call tear space which is
like all the space the walls take up the
hallways and so forth we are really
looking at for a small school
120 square feet all the way up to about
200 square feet
so the law actually caps it up to 168
square feet it's been a while since
we've seen one of those schools that
small for that size so I would take
those years that he took and at least
multiply them by three I did the back
calculation I took his same approach
which I really love so I might give him
some extra credit for that and used his
same approach and it looked like to
compare it to the existing program if
you were a 30 right now our rates differ
between 30 and 60 percent if you were a
more affluent community at 30 percent it
would take you an equivalent of 66 years
then I used 120 square feet per student
for high schools that's probably much
much higher than that if you're at a 66
6 I'm sorry a 60 Grant Community
um less affluent it would take 132 years
at 120 square feet per pupil at 550 a
square foot for a build
thank you I'm just trying to wrap my
head around what you are saying and you
I want to make sure I understood it
correctly you are saying that basically
if we spread the same amount of money
that we are currently spending on
building Aid and we send it equally to
all schools that would result in
basically um you know this uh
funding
not even coming close to the level of
funding that we currently give to a
school that gets approved that's correct
and and
um I'll just repeat my numbers in case
somebody wants to do that again but it's
my numbers were quickly based on
um 120 square feet per per student at
550 square feet uh 550 dollars per
square foot which is about what we're at
I mean because all of those numbers
would change with inflation and so forth
but right would you agree I mean my my
personal opinion is that indicates that
that whole system of Have and Have Nots
is pretty much built into the system
because I hear you say and I don't want
to put words in your mouth I'm genuinely
trying to understand this
would it be fair to say that
that indicates that at the current level
of funding we would never be able to
equity and equitably help everybody
because we basically you know would need
way more funds to just keep paying these
levels of building Aid if everybody
would be applying that is a fair
statement yes I appreciate it and as I
said I'm I'm trying really hard to wrap
my head around this because it's
complicated and I don't want to
misunderstand or mistake something that
you said so I appreciate you taking the
time
um another one of my comments I just
wanted to point out I representative
Buco I think mentioned this was um
comparing Capital costs to operational
costs when I read this bill it does
speak to me a little bit more like you
were saying operationally
um If This Were because for Capital
we're really talking about
um saving this money you know if this
had been in place 40 years ago and
nobody touched that money I'm looking
around the room nobody touched that
money for 40 years yeah maybe that
program would if it was adequately
funded be a reasonable amount of money
for schools to tap into
um how that happens probably this bill
would need to flush that out on how it
doesn't disappear in 40 years
um however if it was more of an
operational fund uh maintenance fund
then that actually might make sense
because schools are using
um boiler Replacements roof Replacements
window repair things like that it does
seem like more of a an operational setup
than a capital setup but not that
there's not a way to do it but just that
that was my thought on it as well and
then uh lastly
uh
uh I think somebody asked about
[Music]
um
temporary classrooms emergency repairs
and a lot of that stuff is in the
building Aid law temporary classrooms
building Aid doesn't pay for there's a
lot of things that probably could be
fleshed out and and trying to make sure
that you're targeting the things that
you're looking to Target uh and then I
guess I'll just say that I'm I'm happy
to answer any questions if you have
questions about the program
to that point if we did if we did use
Gatsby definitions would that satisfy
the instead of trying to Define all
these things can be used for if we if we
just said section session such of gasbee
I'm not familiar with it I mean I'd have
to read through it to see if and the
only thing that I would be able to say
is whether it's similar to building Aid
and versus what you know maybe that
maybe even if it's not similar to
building Aid you're still that's still
something you'd want to Target
um and and maybe this is the intent but
um I'll also say that um a lot of times
uh the focus in our school buildings is
the gymnasium uh it is what people that
drives uh some of the funding so uh if
that really is left up to the community
to tip into those funds whenever they
want I think you may see some really
nice gyms
um whereas uh building Aid there are a
lot of myths on building Aid
um I was trying to think of a good
analogy the other day and um I think it
was well anyway so you know essentially
the you know I
I'm putting myself on record saying this
I realize this but um essentially like
I'm holding a bunch of acorns right and
these acorns like represent square
footage for schools and we only have so
much that we give up to schools
um and we we treat them all the same
what they do with their local portion
and if they want to go gather more
acorns they can we don't prohibit them
from doing that but we are not paying
for a bigger school for one District
versus another District now
theoretically like
um it will be bigger because it's based
on more students or I think or more
special education spaces but they're all
playing on the same set of rules and I
just want to clarify that that
um that I'm not giving any more acorns
to anybody else but they may be asking
for more acorns so um so there I I have
officially embarrassed myself so I like
the Acres you're welcome thank you Mr
chair and since
um
again I'm coming back to My Equity
question what do you think skips the
squirrels that don't ask for our acorns
from coming to you and asking for acorns
and seeing a much longer list of capital
projects waiting for our funding because
you know
right now it seems that there are
certain towns that just don't ever
either get approved or they never even
apply do you have any thoughts on why
that may happen because it is a major
concern of mine I I do I probably have a
strong opinion on that um I I so
building Aid has been very volatile and
even you know so was it in a moratorium
and I realized we talked about the board
Army already but even then it doesn't
come out with any consistent funding I
actually think you have there's three
other bills that try to Target that
um a minimum level of funding would
certainly help schools plan and a
dedicated
um fund you know if you I think House
Bill 2 actually established a dedicated
fund
um build a building Aid fund I think
it's called so having a steady stream of
funding a reliable source of funding
will allow people allow school districts
to plan building Aid has only been out
of a moratorium now for
um for two going on three bienniums so
you had to apply ahead of time
representative Vlad already said House
Bill 452 is working we've been working
really hard with trying to work with
those timelines to kind of help those
timelines out but the first biennium is
kind of like a wash because nobody knew
building Aid was coming out of a
moratorium so then the second biennium
which now we're
um is the biennium we're in right now is
this really the first shot that schools
had at applying for building Aid I had
there's a two-step process in applying
for building Aid one is you submit a
letter called an intent to fund letter
that letter was due January of 2020.
January of 2020 I had 50 schools tell me
that they were going to apply for
building Aid come July of 2020 when you
actually have to submit the application
there was only 12 applicants that
submitted applications so obviously
priorities have shifted a lot so I think
um
the the goal I think with the
legislation is to build a list of
schools and have that list for you all
to see what the ask is uh and for them
to get picked off as they go and if that
list was established we could do that we
now have a list of 17 I think House Bill
452 especially with the amendment will
allow that list to flow a little bit
better and for schools to say if you
were really needed the state's help
you'll get in line if you don't you then
you might go ahead and build on your own
which
um
which is obviously a local decision
whether that they'd want to do that just
a very quick follow-up
you said you know if you don't need
States help
obviously Windham did build a project
without State help and we knew full well
we were not gonna get any
would you say that's the only reason why
schools don't apply or are there are
other reasons for you know smaller
school districts to never apply even
though they may need School help
uh I think so I I care what you're
saying I'm sure that other towns wanted
would appreciate that Assistance or
um want that to be added to their their
reduce their tax rates as well but I
think other schools uh
the house bill 452 I think allows those
schools to stay on the list so even
though smaller projects will start to
creep up the list so I hope that schools
will be able to take that message of oh
we might not be able to build in next
year but we maybe by year three we'll
get our project built
um and I think that they would be
applying for building Aid if they knew
that that list was going to be built
upon
thank you
yeah I know I I've been thinking and I
was going to ask you a question yeah
maybe that light's on but this one is no
uh oh
you're thinking go ahead yeah
20 years ago
we were looking at things that sizes of
the schools in different sizes
I thought we'd passed as a law
elementary schools 120 square feet per
pupil middle schools 140 square feet per
pupil and high school's 160 square feet
there was some acreage in there as well
I argued that at the time in my own town
of Kingston where they were building a
school for 200 square feet per pupil and
I thought this is really crazy and
there's been problems ever since with
leaving a whole Wing empty and now
they've moved the
Middle School into the what had been the
high school because this mismanagement
that was going on
you didn't mention those figures are you
still using them we are yes and a matter
of fact there's three other figures
because it depends on if you're you have
a population of more than 250 students
or less than 250 but yes the that range
is still exists in law and that's the
range we use and that 550 per square
foot seems awful higher this piece from
uh representative Ladd that says
295 square feet per pupil uh so that
wasn't square footage but um cost is
what we're talking about as full cost
um and so
um us construction costs right now
um it it depends on whether you're
talking about construction costs or
project costs construction costs run
about 250 dollars square foot right now
um we've had that's Pro that doesn't
include um construction costs are
probably 12 percent higher now than they
were last year so those are last year's
numbers so we're getting close to 300 a
square foot for construction project
costs include architect engineering fees
site work site development Furniture
fixtures equipment legal fees so forth
that brings you closer to 250 uh closer
to 550 square foot on average thank you
Mr chair okay
other questions
thank you
as always very helpful
anyone else want to comment
does anyone have any additional
questions for representative
okay all right
that being the case uh
oh
I thought you were heading out I don't
know
Mark manganello Bureau of school finance
department of education I haven't had
much time to look over this amendment
but just a couple things uh to point out
to think about
um the bill allocates the funding based
on admr average daily membership in
Residence so that goes to where the
student lives within a particular School
District not where the student is
educated so we have um I didn't do the
math but we have approximately about we
have 180 school districts approximately
and about 15 of those school districts
don't have schools so they tuition all
their students they're financially
responsible for educating the students
so the District of Albany sends all
their students to Conway the school
district of Conway the District of
Albany does not have a school but they
are financially responsible for
educating the students that live in
Albany and so they happen to have
tuition agreement with another school
district and they send those students to
that school district if this amendment
were to pass and it funds based on admr
Albany would receive money money that
according to the amendment is restricted
to be spent on Capital expenditures but
Albany does not have a school so a
potential consideration would be to
allocate based on adma where the student
is educated not where the student is
living so just a technical thing to to
chew on there another thing to think
about and um I've I've passed the
amendment over to Dr Ray
I do not set uh the department of
education does not Implement tax policy
dra implements tax policy so this would
have ramifications for tax policy that I
don't know how dra would would
implement it but one of the questions I
would have for Dra and and they would
work with the Department of Education as
far as how this would impact school
taxes is if we give out 50 million
dollars in fiscal year 24 all of the
budgets for fiscally not all the budgets
a bunch of districts have just had town
meeting they've set their budgets for
fiscal year 24. if they did not
appropriate money for a capital reserve
fund which this funding is designed to
go to
there wouldn't be an appropriation so
there would be Revenue coming in without
an appropriation and the question I
would have for Dra is would dra apply
that automatically against the tax rate
I would say no because it's restricted
but that's something dra would need to
think about so
having this go on fiscal year 24 with
the budgets already in place a city can
do Appropriations on demand they get the
legislative body together
um of districts most districts most
school districts they have to have a
town meeting to get an appropriation so
I'm not sure for fiscal year 24 most
Appropriations have been set at town
meeting where they're having town
meeting this Saturday they'll have it um
before the budget passes likely
um
just something to consider about there's
always this tax implication whenever you
give out Revenue in a year in which the
Appropriations have already been set it
creates tax rate setting challenges so
just a couple two things to think about
it
I just um wanted to ask you and thank
you for taking the questions
emergency projects come to mind right no
money appropriated you have to ask for
aid from the state and obviously you
have to appropriate it does that require
a special meeting
there's I believe there's a provision in
RSA third I think it's 3211 uh 32 colon
11 where you can have an emergency you
can have the commissioner approve it but
you have to have a revenue source to
back it so if the state were to give you
money for an emergency project you could
you could it's a streamlined process
where the commissioner can basically
authorize it
um I think Commissioner of dra and
education authorizes it
um under the municipal Finance act
um that's a very unique situation so if
you had a a terrible thing happen but
you had money to come in then you could
have the appropriation on a streamlined
fashion to get the money in the normal
emergency process is to do it's it's RSA
197 colon 3 you have to go petition a
judge to say we need additional
Appropriations those Appropriations come
from taxpayers not a backed Revenue
Source
um you have to have a town meeting you
have to get a judge to approve it you
have to get 50 voter turnout that's the
normal process thank you just a very
quick follow-up
so if say we you know at some point
decided to do this technically uh we you
don't foresee any issues if the funds
will start coming in the second year of
the bi anymore just talking about
concerns about money in the first year
of the biennium where the appropriation
process is already complete yeah in this
particular concern for uh as far as how
to manage this from a tax rate setting
perspective it gets more complicated for
fiscal year 24 it will be less
complicated in the future years era will
still need to set a policy as far as how
they want to manage this but but it
becomes more complicated and after the
budget's already been set
sure yeah thank you thank you for being
here uh couldn't you uh modify 3211
and just allow it for this Kappa Reserve
fund and have to allow the special
meeting
and you know within within 3211. um
within 32 11 or within hb2 within um
within this amendment if you wanted to
say
um the governing body if you wanted to
Grant the ultimately the state has full
authority to give power to the political
subdivision so if you wanted to say
something to the effect of
the governing body shall have the uh
authority to appropriate this funding
something like that in this bill that
would make the appropriation there
without going through the legislative
body
um well I uh if I if I made interrupt
here you need you need a warrant to
establish a capital reserve fund correct
so I mean that's we could do it within
hp2 then you could do it with yeah you
could create a new process that doesn't
involve you could create a more
streamlined process than current current
law it'll end up in 32 basically though
right I mean it sort of
32 is your budget law 32 32 just has a
particular provision that where you'd
want to put that what you're describing
you might want to put it in a different
RSA but but you could put it into law
thank you and a quick follow-up since we
are already dipping the weeds we may as
well dig a little bit deeper
um obviously this issue arises from the
fact that we would be sending the money
to the town the state would hand the
money off to the town and the town would
need an appropriate place to hold it
um is there any other situation where
you've seen the state you know say this
is the money that I want to send you
once you have your vehicle I will send
it to you and in the meantime I'll hold
it or would that be a very Arcane and
strange solution I'm just trying to
think out loud and I know I may end up
in a bad corner but so it's it's
typically
uh most grants operate on a
reimbursement basement so the
expenditure is already there
uh I'm not aware of any grant that this
grant is novel in a sense that it it's
it's it's creates a it's funding for a
reserve fund and so just basically to
feed a reserve fund all you need is an
appropriation at the local level so
that's that's the only missing component
no most grants are done on an
expenditure reimbursement basis so the
expenditure is already there the
expenditure is there then the
Appropriations already there then the
revenue is going to back the
appropriation and it's just a a wash but
this is a little bit unique I'm just
trying to figure it out because as you
said you do need a word Antarctica you
know whether it's in a special meeting
or in a regular meeting to create that
capital reserve fund and there is a
theoretical possibility voters in a town
strangers may be they would not approve
this vehicle to keep money from the
state and then what and I did a quick
analysis it looks about half of school
districts have money in a capital
reserve fund
so so some some districts and a school a
district that doesn't have a school
would have no interest in a capital
reserve fund um so some districts do not
have capital reserve funds
I'm sorry
do you have any questions
okay
thank you very much
well based on the testimony we've heard
today I think this needs a little more
homework
so I don't think we're in a position to
take any action on this at this time
yeah Mr chair I
heartedly I also
a pretty big task already
I think maybe we've allocated enough
expense of resources in time today to
this issue and maybe
considering the other work before us we
should
um move on consider moving on
we will break for lunch and Hope
representative lab
now through to next November and that we
get some we get some support from
Finance people here to be on that
because we're looking at all these
topics and issues and I really
appreciate the admr and adma issue
whereas we have a number of kids up my
way their High School experience is in
Vermont
and we're certainly not going to be
funding uh Capital costs in Vermont and
yet they have no High School within
their K-8 district and but they have
they have 9 through 12 students that
they tuition out uh so that's a huge
issue right here that was just brought
up that you were going to have to
sometime how Rectify that but I'd we are
going forward with this study and and uh
without having to have any commission or
committee set up by the legislature
we're doing it as a subcommittee of a
bill we have I welcome people to attend
and work with us on that
just a quick question thank you Mr chair
representative thank you for taking the
question
when we talk about school districts that
tuition out their students right would
it be a fair statement to say that the
costs for maintaining the building by
whatever District educates the kids are
passed to the town that you know pay
tuition in one form or another
well I was talking primarily about those
which were sending the St Johnsbury
Academy up in St Johnsbury Vermont uh
we're paying around at twenty thousand
twenty point two thousand dollar tuition
costs I'm sure they're building
something in but that's an independent
school
that's approved by the state of New
Hampshire and the state of Vermont so it
it's just a complicated issue how we
handle that thank you you're welcome
it's taking our note yeah thank you
thank you Mr chairman
thank you again for being here and
you'll probably in your travels
all right uh have you heard of a bottom
to the waterfall
of the decrease in population of a
number of students in the state because
that you know
I don't know I don't know where it's
going but there is a bottom that uh
somebody predicting uh we're seeing that
waterfall effect throughout New England
we're not just seeing it in K through 12
our colleges are really hurting as a
result of that in fact that's why you
see Maine underscoring our tuition rates
being they're trying to drag them all
over at their in-state tuition now and
Amherst is doing the same thing and
Lowell's doing the same thing to us so
uh this is a huge huge issue our
demographic you know it was up to 210
215 000 kids when we started here
exactly and now we're down what 160 4
000. it's in it's in 150s actually it's
huge according to the commissioner
and that's so you haven't heard
basically uh well I've heard it hello at
the University level that we're dealing
with this and we're dealing that's
impacting our Capital costs too and and
what we're doing for new construction
and where the emphasis
the governor is going to put 9 million
in the hockey rink I think that's a
great idea but
um it's it's uh
it's an issue that's compounded
everywhere you look and we're also
dealing with the issue then like at
Plymouth state that they have no housing
now for their students uh especially in
the Master's level and so they have
that's an issue there it's we have these
places all through the state which have
different needs and and every one of
them similar well except for a few
schools districts in South where we know
the demographic is growing
but that's that's a rarity in this state
right now it's it's going the other
direction for sure
thank you
all right thank you after lunch we will
be taking up adequacy
and also
um we've got to finish up
HP tube between now and Monday morning
so enjoy your lunch we'll see you back
here at one o'clock
you gotta love it
okay
foreign
we will reconvene
okay
we have a sheet that was just passed out
looks like this and there's some extras
up here on the
one does have it for anybody that's here
who wants to take a look at the same
thing
thank you
and actually Mickey put this together
for me based on my wild ideas which I'm
now backing off on just so you know up
front uh
yeah once you hit the total button
that wasn't a good idea
uh
what this is
well why don't you explain what it is
so if you remember when we met losing
track of days welcome to the Wednesday I
think perhaps we discussed the
governor's Ed funding formula I walked
us through a very detailed spreadsheet
of that and that was the one that looked
like this
and one of the consensuses my takeaway
from that day's work session was to
run some numbers and see what it looked
like if we reduced the increase proposed
to the base Aid and the free reduced
lunch Aid category of differentiated Aid
and allocated those funds in the more
targeted Aid components of the formula
so this is the taking from the left and
adding to the right we've heard that
terminology and staying within the
governor's recommended budget
Appropriations for the biennium
so
I think we've talked about this and
those who have done this for years know
there's countless ways to do Ed funding
there's so many different components so
many variables different Grant amounts
different thresholds so there's there's
almost infinite ways to come up with it
so this is just one right so this
document here it's a Word document set
up and a landscape orientation on the
legal I tried to build out breakout
rather the different components of the
Ed funding formula
in the current law
the middle represents the governor's
recommended budget and the far right
represents what I'm calling proposal
number one so we've one thing I've
learned and Mark can remember this from
four years ago if we don't number
different scenarios it's really hard to
keep track so this was number one so
that's so you may see if if I run
numbers again over the weekend on Monday
maybe I'll have numbers three four and
four whatever so I that's that's what
number one rep represents there
so the main differences here
starting on that first row across this
is your cost of an adequate education so
these are the cost factors your base and
free and reduced lunch special education
English language Learners and third
grade reading
you'll see in current law the amounts
are the same in both years and under
current law if you recall we have a
biennial CPI adjustment which is why the
amounts are the same for fiscal 24 and
25.
jumping over to the governor's column
you'll see the big increase for base so
from 3866 up to forty seven hundred
dollars and the big increase for fnr so
from just under 1933 up to 2500. special
education English language Learners
remain the same
third grade reading is repealed and
you'll notice the second year
fiscal 25 it's different numbers than
the first year and that's because the
governor's budget includes changing that
biennial CPI adjustment to an annual two
percent adjustment
on the bottom of that cell you'll see
898.9 million and 24
916.8 million in 2025 compared to the
previous column to the left you'll see
there's a that's where most of the jump
is if if not really all and the
governor's recommended budget
jumping over to proposal number one
it basically makes no material changes
or significant changes rather to the the
amounts except just rounds them up to
the next hundred dollars
why I did this I don't know the
direction to was to essentially take it
and I think my brain likes round numbers
and rather than having the uh 3 866
dollars and 18 cents I thought 3 900 was
a nice round number so again all these
are variables that can be changed in
statute whatever committee the direction
the committee wants to go so proposal
number one does include
an increase to the cost of an adequate
education in each of the components base
fnr sped and English language learners
but not nearly to the extent of the
governors which you'll see in that next
row down 755 million dollars versus 898
but compared to current law it's about 7
million Statewide which is somewhat
rounding you know and that's what these
essentially are is rounded up
but also does maintain the two percent
annual increase that the governor's
budget recommends
which you see that breakout in the next
subset so Aid component adjustments
I talked about the CPI adjustment that's
in current law the biennial CPI
adjustment the middle column two percent
adjustment the governor's recommended
house pill to on the cost of an adequate
education that first subset we just went
through
in The Proposal I applied the two
percent annual adjustment to not only
the cost of an adequate education but
also to the additional Aid based on free
and reduced lunch to the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and the extraordinary
needs Grant both on the grants and the
thresholds so those equalized valuation
per pupil thresholds are fixed in
statute currently so this two percent
would apply to those thresholds which
would align with what we usually see for
valuations increasing over time and for
inflationary reasons
foreign
any questions to this point or should I
proceed
go ahead so
never mind sorry we're just discussing
assumptions I can I can hold questions
thank you Mr chair
uh making in the first box
where it's current law
you said both years this is 24 or 25 and
both years are the same
that's the way current law would be that
both years would stay the same under
current law the adjustment to those
amounts occurs every biennium so that's
why it's the same for 24 and 25. thank
you
swept and the governors and this
proposal won uh from the statutory 363
million dollars
on page two so this is where I started
to
try to do what the committee had kind of
guided me towards which was targeting
some of the AIDS so that first row we
went over we really reduced the cost of
an adequate education components so now
it's reallocating those those dollars to
the targeted components so the first is
additionally based on frame reduced
lunch and I put slash relief funding
because
relief funding under current law and the
additional Aid and free and reduced
lunch that's in House Bill 529 are
very similar they're almost identical so
rather than build out another F and R
category I just superseded it
essentially
so in current law the scale of those
grants goes from 150 to 600 per f r
student based on how elevated your
friend reduce lunch population is among
your total students but then that Grant
amount is prorated to 17 and a half
million dollars a year so that's why
you'll see in the far left 17 and a half
million per year is associated with
relief funding
the governor proposed repealing this Aid
component so that's why there's nothing
here for the Governor's recommended
column and then in proposal one this is
essentially the language from House Bill
529 would replace
the relief funding as it is so there
would be no
17 and a half million dollar proration
anyway the formula would just run how it
how it runs and based on the data we're
using is about 16.7 in the first year
and 17.1 in the second year
another component of House Bill 529 was
fiscal capacity disparity Aid
so the amounts on here for the next two
components is where I uh
just put in plugs for lack of a better
term so 350 dollars per pupil but kept
the 600 000 to 1.6 million dollar
thresholds so this would be 350 per
pupil
and then it would be scaled down to zero
depending on where that Town's equalized
valuation per pupil fell between 600 000
and 1.6 million so Statewide it's 13.7
and 15.2 million respectively in fiscal
24 and 25.
the big targeted component of proposal
number one would be extraordinary needs
Grant so this is a Formula that
currently exists our component that
currently exists
under current law at 650 per f r student
not for every student just per F and R
student based on the equalized valuation
per F and R pupil that's the difference
between extraordinary needs
and fiscal capacity disparity Aid so
extraordinary needs Blends equalized
valuation and fnr
in current law it's about 9.7 million
dollars associated with this grant
Statewide
this was uh essentially unchanged and
the governor's recommended budget for 24
and 25. there are s it does uh
accelerate in the future years and 26
and Beyond and I'll get to I think I
actually have that noted here so
beginning in fiscal 26 it's increased by
50 each of the next five biennia
and I think we've talked about this we
usually just do a two-year look in the
finance committee I know the department
and the governor's office did a 10-year
forecast I don't have anything on that
for any of the proposals that I'll
probably be doing for you
very quickly if you think it's useful if
not necessary for this cycle if not
necessarily for this cycle because we
only have a few days but for future work
I I would appreciate if you'd explored
with the governor's office if they would
want to you know share or work together
on those models so maybe we can acquire
some that some of that ability to
forecast for the longer term I do agree
that for this cycle we are we have what
we have and we're out of time but maybe
for the future that may uh help
everybody uh you know see things through
the same perspective
so proposal number one the equalized
valuation per pupil or excuse me for
free and reduced lunch people for
Extraordinary needs as a 3 500 per pupil
Grant so this is a massive increase this
is where most of the targeting and
proposal one occurs is in the
extraordinary needs Grant section so
that's where you'll see
51.7 million and 54 million as opposed
to just under 10 million per year under
current law
foreign
just so you know I'm the one that put my
thumb on the scale on this
when we were talking about it last week
and I said well why don't we try to
reconfigure this so that this
poor quote poor towns got a bigger
piece so that that was my thumb pretty
heavy thumb as it turns out
question right uh yeah I have uh an
issue because free reduced is based on
the forms that have turned in
and that's a big problem for my school
because like I've said before we have
about 760 students
and 144 have not turned into forms as
opposed to last
term this proposal makes no
no changes to any of that process so so
that that issue is a real one that we've
discussed a lot in this committee
applies to current law the governor's
plan and this other proposal so that's
not I don't know where the committee
wants to go to deal with that situation
but I think the the uh value
valuation equalized valuation takes that
into account that that will but still
you're you know your 144 short so that
that skews the
what what you have
by a great margin not a little margin
even even with equalized valuation but
the equalized valuations I understand it
for 529
was in lieu of
the head count for free right free and
reduced right right so it it
says this town deserves more because of
its valuation per student not how many
forms you got right right well that's I
just want to make you know I just want
to make sure that that's that's what's
happening because I I was in agreement
with 529 and what Farmington gets
so in The Proposal one column the three
targeted Aid that I just walked through
the relief funding fiscal capacity and
then extraordinary needs the easy way to
look at those is one is targeted based
on just free and reduced lunch one is
targeted based on just equalized
valuation and the third is targeted on
both okay so it this is kind of a wave
and when you look at the columns and I
don't have a town by town with the
details when you look at the columns
some towns will get one some will get
the other some may get two of the three
some may get so it's
it's a way to cast a wider net to Target
based on those criteria
and if you look at this you can see what
this does in your town
so the other major difference between
the this proposal one and the governors
and current law is the stabilization
Grant so under current law that amount
is still the amount calculated back in
fiscal 12. that's unchanged
in the governor's recommended budget the
stabilization Grant was repealed
completely and replaced with a hold
harmless which we'll get to here shortly
and then proposal one this assumes a
five percent reduction per year
so going to a 95 of the stabilization of
fiscal 24 and 90 of it in fiscal 25.
if this committee were to
explore a phase out of that we would you
would just need to consider what would
you want the law to be in fiscal 26 and
Beyond so like I said this this I'm only
calculating two years at this point but
should we draft an amendment for a plan
you would want to have some law in place
to apply beyond the biennium okay thank
you Mr chair Mickey quick question
I thought we were the governor's plan
was to end the stabilization in 10 years
you are saying five percent a year that
implies 20 years
so the governor's plan eliminates the
stabilization Grant the old the one I
was into it immediately and replaces it
with a whole harmless right that would
be phased out in 10 years
what this proposal here does is keeps
the stabilization Grant as we know it
intact less five percent per year
so it's you've got the stabilization
which was what is an originally a whole
harmless but we refer to that as a
stabilization the governor eliminates
that and replaces it with a new hold
harmless which
forget the numbers for now
given what happened the last time we
tried to keep the stabilization Grant
and we remove it over time it may not be
a position that I can be comfortable
with at all but again conclusions at the
end and so on and so forth and you bring
up a good point uh six years ago seven
years ago or now whatever it was we did
a four percent reduction in law lasted
two years and was repealed essentially
yeah the reason you see a slower burn if
you will of the stabilization Grant is
my direction when I left the other day
was stay within the governor's
parameters of total spending but Target
Aid and
it's hard to Target Aid to towns that
rely on the stabilization while also
getting rid of the stabilization so to
to bring the stabilization down
significantly or gone all the way it's
near impossible based on the
appropriation levels and the governor's
recommended budget to give additional
money to some of those needier
communities so that's why it's like this
but again this is uh not a
recommendation in any way it's just a
illustration appreciated
right uh thank you uh does this which
which proposal does the chart of towns
what's that equal to is that the one the
right hand right hand side the right
hand side yes okay I'm good
so you'll see on that stabilization row
about 157 million dollars a year as
current law
this would go to 149 and 141.7
respectively or 24 and 25 so you see
that phase out certainly it's still
mostly there but again this to to
achieve the directives I this is just
what this model it maintains most of
that stabilization Grant
questions that really was my question
but it the 149 and the one 41 those are
the costs those are costs
that's just how much the stabilization
grants Statewide would be uh would would
total so you'll and the current loss
Statewide it's about 157 million dollars
in this proposal one it's down to 149
and 141. thank you so the whole harmless
Grant uh this is where the governor
recognized that some towns perhaps would
be uh getting less money so there's a
whole harmless Grant to ensure that no
total adequacy Grant plus swept would be
less than what the 2024 preliminary
published estimates were by the
Department of Education so those came
out in November and that is the Baseline
for the hold harmless so whatever
everything up to this point calculates
in the governor's plan if that ends up
being less than what they would have
received under the published preliminary
estimate they get an amount equal to
that difference so that's why you'd see
many of the towns on the town by town
that we went through last week would
have zero most of those are attributable
to either they're in excess webtown so
they're just not impacted by the
governor's proposal or they're held
harmless so basically everything adding
up in House Bill 2 as it came to you
would just equal the same amount that
they got the year before so that's why
that column difference column is zero
question yeah this is something I've
always been puzzling over and I guess
I'm finally brave enough to ask it
um
with regards to
you know the history of the
stabilization grants with regards to the
home heartless Grant with your proposal
um where it's going down from 95 90 you
know it's there's still a reduction
going across time and presumably the
schools are still going to need those
funds across time so where is the
expectation that where is going who's
going to fill in those funds that five
percent the 10 you know what I mean
there's like we're always reducing stuff
but the school's not reducing anything
so where does that get filled back in
so the way and for the record I I know
you didn't mean my proposal but this
isn't my I know you didn't mean that but
for the record not my proposal um what
this formula would do is the two percent
increase annual increase both in the
cost and adequate Education Plus those
targeted Aid components are going to go
up two percent every year so that'll cut
into the stabilization loss over time
similar to the governor's approach of
enhancing extraordinary needs over a
decade while phasing out the whole
harmless
since I'm new just trying to understand
this correctly
um
I think the governor's intent in getting
rid of the stabilization grants and
replacing it with a different uh you
know approach to you know for now to
make sure nobody loses dollars out of it
was to remove the um very likely
unintended consequences of our choice to
guarantee stabilization Aid at Dollar
levels regardless of the number of
students which is basically resulting in
sometimes getting way more than they
should reasonably get but because we
made a promise and that's the formula
that's what it is and it is my
understanding Governor wanted to fix it
in a way in which nobody would lose
money so we don't have the whole we are
getting less money is just
changing things so that you know this
will slowly get taken out of the system
without anybody losing a dollar in the
process so
do I sorry I'm just trying to wrap my
head around it am I under am I
characterizing that correctly I I think
the governor's office so Adam crapo from
the governor's office is here and I
think at some point perhaps he can no
way I got it speak to the governor's
intents could we use the governor's
approach
and and on this proposal one
and do away with have a substitute for
stabilization
because the home holds the stabilization
and basically the hold harmless of doing
the same thing
just out of different definitions
they they the stabilization did the same
thing as the whole harmless back in
2012. it's it's not quite Apples to
Apples any longer so by
maintaining the old stabilization and we
know that that's based on very old data
and very old information and then doing
targeted Aid above and beyond that
that would generate additional funds
going to
needier towns in this biennium
versus keeping them flat at what current
law would have given those needier towns
by just doing a whole harmless and
that's and that's a policy decision for
the committee but that's the that's the
main difference of really what you're
trying to achieve with with this
proposal so just to rephrase if if the
higher uh contributions to the town
kicks in then the whole hold harmless
would be eliminated
in theory yeah so the more Target the
more Aid you do the less hold harmless
would be necessary right yeah it's but I
can tell you it's
it's very difficult for 240 plus
communities in their issues to craft a
formula and some of those stabilization
grants for certain towns are
I'm gonna pick on Berlin I always pick
on Berlin their their stabilization
Grant is a greater dollar amount than
their calculated cost of an adequate
education
so to take that entirely away for Berlin
and to try to
make that up in a targeted Aid component
it's it just can't happen not especially
within the the appropriation levels in
house bill one as they came to the
governor's appropriation levels and
that's that's part of the issue so
it really depends on your policy with
this what direction you want to go and
how you want to carry carry it on uh but
it is a difficult thing for sure okay
well let's go through it then we'll
revisit so just finishing up quickly
hold harmless Grant yes the governor's
recommended budget does phase that out
over over uh 10 years uh
in total 87.1 million in fiscal 24 and
79.7 million in fiscal 25 are
attributable to the hold harmless in the
governor's budget
The Proposal one also carries a hold
harmless but it's it's much smaller and
mainly because stabilization Grant is
still intact so there's a lot more
targeted Aid in proposal one which
necessitates less of a hold harmless at
the end of the day
lastly the final row across I summarized
the total appropriation including
adequacy grants and the swept which is
raised locally and retained locally and
uh so you can see the governor's budget
was about 120 million over the biennium
more than current law and this proposal
one stays basically at the same level
for the for the two years
thank you
and then
if there's any other questions would be
thumb
s
I I want just on the last row on the
totals can you just go over what you
just said again
so under current law for the biennium if
you made no changes the estimate is
about
1.925 billion dollars thank you
and and the governor's recommended
budget and and what total of uh this
proposal one comes out to is about the
same just over two billion dollars 2.044
billion thank you
technical question here
um
since you know the proposals are
you know they are similar in dollars
right in here so what we try to do with
this model is to
change priorities of certain you know
move funds from one pocket to the other
but end up with a similar total budget
so we can see that whether the second
proposal
is has more Merit right
is that what we're trying to do just you
know my my takeaway from our last
meeting was to the governor's increase
was mainly in the cost of an adequate
education portion which is a across the
board and to essentially reduce that and
then take those funds and Target them so
yes but get to the same bottom line so
then we have the same bottom line and we
can see how the money moves from one
town to the other right what what I may
ask if at all possible and I know it's
not something you have on you right now
I know that we already have a list of
how the towns do Under the governor
proposals and now we have the list of
how the towns do here if we could merge
those and have them side by side and we
may have to go to printing landscape
instead of uh this way but it would be
kind of nice to see how the money moves
around without having to take two
separate spreadsheets identify the same
town and you know
I know not for today but maybe for when
we meet tomorrow or yep and I thought of
that
too late today to produce but I can
certainly put that and that probably
would be helpful to at least see the
town by Town differences I uh but yes
you do have the information on two
different documents right now so it's it
doesn't do the math yeah so appreciate
it
Mary thank you Mr chair we had talked a
little bit about maybe adding um maybe
20 million in each year that biennium is
still is that still on the table for
discussion
and how would that impact
that depends where you want to put the
20 million so again
um this was just an illustration of if
you built out 529s if you layered 529 on
top of essentially the governor's plan
here's a way to do it and spend the same
dollars that's a different approach than
the governors from here ideally I would
have some specifics if you want me to
run like a committee consensus for
instance rather than be
coming up with what I think might be
good you know I maybe did that a little
bit more than I should have with this
one as it is so I'd like it I can tell
you this uh in Hampton the tar and
feathers
are getting in place for their rep
because what what this effectively did
was take the increase in the base
away
so while it's been stated we're going to
increase the base adequacy by X
uh this takes it away so I don't I don't
get to go back home again
so I think it was a well-intended idea
not not the right answer
because I like living in Hampton so but
if you know I think I agree with you
about I think that this is a good
starting point and it gives for me
visually at this point there are levers
that we can lift up and down uh with you
and on page one
um you maintain or this proposal
maintains the base of the 3900 as
opposed to the 4700 you've got levers
now with your program of let's see what
it looks like if we move the base up to
4200 so there still is an increase
overall here but this still leaves more
targeted money on this side that we can
use for for the other programs to answer
that question I asked that question he
had an answer for it yeah I'm sure every
hundred dollars is 16 million
every 100 increase on this is a 16
million dollar decision in the base
that's fine I mean that's so that's
let's play a little bit
one I'm sorry to bring it up
an estimate uh without a lot of support
this is what we need so I think there's
maybe a little room there
is saying having 40 million for the year
which isn't a number of things
if I may just quickly address the point
just made
um I think the 16 million was a forecast
of what uh the you know we estimate
those expenses may be and I think that
we do need to keep in mind that you know
a law that has a cost and we have to
account for that in the budget so I
would just look for any funds in other
places because
these are very intriguing discussions
right what happens when you move money
from the left side to the right side and
I think this committee really needs to
explore that because
it does change the way certain issues
may get addressed and it may very well
make the formula more fair and I think
that's our job to do in the next three
days
um but you know I would probably not
argue in you know for taking from there
EFA funds are in here
it's not like those if you
they're adequacy dollars
it's out of the trust but I'm talking
about the adequacy but you know to your
point I would have to argue that it's a
guesstimate it's not based in re um real
um predictions of the future it's a
guesstimate so there's there's a gray
area there it's a broad spectrum
I don't care if you get done huh
so Mr chair could I just weigh in for a
moment um so I represent one of the
um excess swept towns
um or or towns with a higher property
value similarly to you and Hanover New
Hampshire and and lime and um
um it is my Town's commitment to
um to not be too overzealous in the you
know the governor's proposal our
position
which I've been told
um is that we have an obligation to help
the rest of the states poorer
communities
with their educational needs and you
know part of part of our commitment to
our state and you know for our
businesses and for our you know
educational system is to to make sure
the students coming out regardless of
what ZIP code can be wonderful workers
regardless of where they land in New
Hampshire so
so
you know hanovers and limes position is
that if we have to give a little from
our own benefit to help the rest of the
state it's only going to help our whole
community so we would all benefit in
that so
um
you know it's not I'm not going to
receive the same kind of um pushback or
reception as you will receive but I
think that there are other
representatives and towns across the
state who will agree with our position
as well is that for everyone who may
receive
a little difficulty with making this
decision there will be another town
pushing for it so you know as evenly
divided as the house is right now I
think you can see that to be possibly a
very accurate or a true statement in
that you know there are plenty of people
on both sides of the issue right now
yeah just wanted to add that I'm kind of
in the same boat as representative as
representative Hayden Phillips I come
from a town where if we take money from
the left side and put it in the right
side I am reducing funding to my own
town but
um as much as I'm elected by my own town
to represent them it's my darn job to
make this fair for the entire state so
everything is a consideration and
obviously I don't want to hurt my town
but I think it's our job to do this in
the best interest of everybody in the
state and you know regardless of the uh
you know
emails I may be getting if anybody's
watching and I'm one of the people who
actually tell us people what I'm doing
in the legislature so sooner or later
the questions will be here but again I
see our job to do what's right for
everybody and you know
uh thank you Mr chairman yeah one of the
dirty words in the in the state as far
as this concern is donut towns and
that's you know if we can do it without
being that that that being involved uh
you know and and you know I appreciate
come from a poor town
you know that you're willing to help us
out I mean but like stabilization
stabilization joke
because those numbers are so far off and
it doesn't really reflect actually
what's happening in the town and I I'm
not I'm not going to say why because it
would incriminate me but uh I'm like I
can be off the stand now Mr chairman
Mary just thank Mr chair so it sounds
like we all kind of agree on the fact
that we're trying to achieve what we had
discussed before that we want
more Equity
um delivered to those communities who
are less able that are less able to pay
and the question is what is the best
route to do that
without causing too much heartache in
the more wealthy towns
and I truly think that maybe thinking
just we do have money in the trust fund
that we could draw upon and I think
first I want to thank Mickey too Mickey
has done unbelievable work he's been
working on these formula for day and
night and he's going way above and
beyond I I think we probably have the
most Superstar LBA person in the world
because he really has worked a lot but
um he's given us some potential ideas
and now it's up to us to think about
if if we truly believe
that we all want to see more equitable
distribution of funds for those towns
that need it the most what's the best
way to do it
is that our assumption yes
thank you uh what what is the five
percent uh stabilization equal
about 8 million I think somewhere around
there
was my thought would be to increase the
base
uh to
by 300 which would equal 38 38 Grand
I mean 38 million 38 Grand right yeah
right
and I will say that that number is a
a raw number just on the ADM 160 000
whatever there depending on what formula
you do the rest of the way there could
be some netting involved with so if you
increase some over here but you still
maintain a big hold harmless it may cut
into how much you need for the whole
harmless and it may net out so uh it's
not always an easy math exercise so just
add this column and add that one right
it doesn't always sum on the other end
just because of some netting that may
occur so just putting that disclaimer
out there okay
my attitude right now is to increase by
48 million I'm sorry I did the math
wrong uh
48 million in the base
uh so that that goes up to
and then I think that they'll put the
fire out on the tar
it may not so for some time I can tell
you that you know for excess webtowns
for you to get additional money you'd
have to no longer be in excess swept
town so it really depends on Hampton's
it is adding 300 in base enough to kick
you over to tip you over to getting a
state Grant or are you still going to be
in excess swept town and it'll be a
different number for Hampton or Hanover
or Windham so and but I can run that and
see what it looks like I don't think
right now
that calculation is at the local level
I don't think the town the
superintendent of schools is sitting
there with the calculator you know
having an understanding all I with the
superintendent of school is seeing is
the base is not going to go to 4 700
it's going to go to
39 here but if we take it to 41 so it's
not going to go to 47 it's going to go
to 41.
and I'll run that but you may end up
seeing no change in some of the excess
swept towns that's the only thing I'm
saying but but if but if but if you want
to sell an increase of that or not sell
but message that then have that be part
of the plan then absolutely I just I'm
just looking at one number to say get
get the base up to 4 100 and everything
else stays the same
yeah you know I think we're agreeing I
might even propose to go a little bit
higher but I think to try to do it that
way it's a cell to say we've increased
the base adequacy for everybody and we
have also increased money for targeted
schools and what we do for all the you
know for students around the state
benefits the entire State regardless of
where you live but I agree that we need
to you know we can take away the entire
increase to the base but I think we can
split that difference it's not exactly
the right phrase but raise that up and
use that extra money to
um do the targeted programs and I guess
that won't be as much as what you've put
in the targeted programs but it's still
a way forward and once we have a sense
of that as representative he said there
may be money in the trust fund that we
can use to boost that targeted side of
the program
yeah if I may ask Mickey because I think
this is a reasonable approach and um you
know we just gotta figure out the
numbers right and we only have a few
hours pretty much left
um
so um I just wanted to ask Nikki you
know how unwieldy is the spreadsheet is
it something that I could maybe ask you
to share that you know whatever
spreadsheet is generated in a way in
which you know you have the
parameters of the various changes that
you made and I can try to play with the
model a little until tomorrow or maybe
on a Sunday before we get here because
if if we have to ask you to do something
and you bring it back to us tomorrow and
then we ask you to do one more thing we
have two shots to ask you for something
before we gotta reach a conclusion if
that spreadsheet is manageable
we I could you know every member could
play with it and say hey I think the
best balance is that this this number
and we can try to you know figure it out
with that is that something that can be
shared and handled reasonably well or
what is the rule that would prevent that
from being shared I don't you know I'm
new there's no rule our policy is
generally not to share our workbooks
just because okay that's fine the
quality control really so we just worry
about it going out and getting used and
looking like oh our LBA calculated this
when there could have been something
it's not it's not what I use is not
really something for public consumption
or or another user the alternative to
that is for me to get your cell phone
number and you should be available in a
week but that doesn't mean that we can't
talk offline and try to come up with
something that may be a tool that a
member could use this weekend if you
want to try to I appreciate it very much
I'm really encouraged Mr chair about
where this discussion is going
um I just wanted to throw another
element
um in the mix so um
my understanding from from our
conversation is that it sounds like
there's an appetite to
if not completely get rid of
stabilization to find some sort of happy
medium balance in which stabilization
can be reduced but you know continue to
fall off the the tail
um
you know to be phased out over time and
um is there is there I'm asking the
committee is there like a comfort level
from a starting point maybe we can give
Mickey two scenarios to kind of
play with the stabilization numbers as
well so that when we're looking at this
new base we also have
you know like a stabilization at 50 or a
stabilization at 75 percent or you know
whatever it is to start looking at what
that number would look like to see you
know obviously we're gonna have a little
bit of cushion it sounds like with the
new base number from the governor's
total
um amount so it sounds like
stabilization may also be able to be
tweaked
um and I think part of this is semantics
because
make hole
has a a ceiling on it where
stabilization has a fixed dollar amount
so because I I look at make hole a form
of stabilization
so
so perhaps perhaps one thing that may
help is
do you want to look at the education
trust fund where we are with that and
maybe if we start settling on some of
the items in there you'll have a clear
idea of where your what your balance is
and what you want to leave whether you
want to drain it to zero or leave some
balance in the education trust fund it
may back into how much money you have
for this before we go there yeah just
one quick you know feedback to this
I agree with chairman emmeric that right
now you know the funding is not really
removed it's just put in a different
formula and a different way of doing it
so stabilization is essentially
immediately placed
I I want to say that I don't think I can
support any form of budget that still
has the stabilization as is again
because of the history where we we know
we know it has to be removed we try to
remove it it got reversed if we leave it
in place as it is and start committing
the same thing will happen and we just
cannot do that again so
because what we are doing here is
essentially you know it's just creating
formulas that will not harm the
stabilization towns but remove the
stabilization altogether and solving
that issue that is really the only
outcome and the only you know process
that I'm I'm comfortable with at this
time because again it it does make
everybody you know
whole but it doesn't have this trap
where we could end up reverting to that
situation which I cannot support so I
guess it's a long answer but
before before we did carry on did you
want to hear from Adam in the governor's
office well this stuff's fresh in your
head before we by all means let me step
aside here
how are you I'm Adam crapo uh with the
governor's office
so I think I what I'm hearing today is I
I think with the proposal that the
governor put forward actually gets us
pretty close to where you guys are
thinking to be honest
and the reason why I think that is
because we we are increasing base and we
are increasing fnr on the left hand side
of the formula
um but what we're doing while we're
doing that is we are get we are phasing
out stabilization or we're getting rid
of stabilization we're phasing out the
whole harmless that fills in the gap for
towns who who lose some funding
um
over time and so
the other piece of that is we're also
over over the 10 years every two years
we're increasing extraordinary needs
grants which basically it's the most
efficient way I think to Target Aid
under our formula uh to the neediest
towns if you will
um you are taking fnra or f r numbers
and you're looking at that and you're
also looking at property evaluations and
you're looking at that and I think you
know we we have two-year estimates here
but I think that kind of paints a
partial picture right of where where
this formula is going because some towns
are receiving additional funding in the
first two years and some aren't but over
time as stabilization phases out and or
uh the whole harmless phases out and
the extraordinary needs grants phases in
um at greater amounts the towns that
have extraordinary needs grants now uh
will likely I mean should property
valuations and enrollment stay
similar I mean it's going to change over
time but and it's sort of difficult to
predict that over the 10 years right
um they will see an increase in eight
and so I think that is the purpose of
the proposal is to
um
you know it's the get rid of
stabilization grants which are based on
Antiquated data
um you know make some towns whole
through the whole harmless and while
that whole harmless phases out you are
introducing additional Aid to the towns
that I I would say need it the most
um and and that's that's sort of I guess
my pitch for that
um but I think it gets I think it gets
us pretty close to to what you're what
you're describing in this committee
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Adam it's been nice meeting you and
working with you
um my my big concern is
we somehow have changed and I think Mark
you can agree we every year we've done
something pretty close
um 10 years is a long time in the world
of funding and administrations change
and people come in and go out and their
ideas tend to go with them
so my concern is that that
you have a lot of good stuff I like a
lot of the ideas that are in there but
my fear is that they won't be
materialized over time
understood and that and that obviously
is up to you know legislatures in the
future and and future Governors however
um I I do think that
under this proposal is a long-term
proposal I think the idea was to fix
this formula in perpetuity and do the
right thing for the state instead of
kind of looking at it into to your
increments and I think for for you know
how long I can remember on this we kind
of look at it to your increments and
then we throw all these Band-Aids on
that's how we have so many pieces of the
formula
and unfortunately that we have relief
Aid where it's like 17 and a half
million here we have um third grade
reading aid which I think it's less than
a million rate mark
yeah or two million uh we have little
pieces here and there it makes it very
complicated for the average member of
the public to pick the thing up and say
this is how my school is funded this is
how
you know we we do things here in New
Hampshire and I think the idea was not
only to fund the neediest towns over
time while they're still while
stabilization phases out increased base
aid for every school
um increase for f r for every every
school who has free kids with free
introduced lunch
um
I think that's that's the most I think
that what you're describing this this
actually accomplishes what what you guys
are talking about well just to follow up
on
we've talked about the f r numbers and
my concerns our school districts um
they're seeing drops in enrollment the
fnr numbers are totally skewed down
words
um so our school districts are going to
get hit because we've we've been on
numbers that were pre-covered and now
we're on actuals and the actuals are so
different from what they were in 2019
this budget doesn't really accommodate
for that for those losses
so I think the attempt in this budget
was to account for should the
legislature move forward with Medicaid
direct certification it would add folks
to the to uh the fnr uh category and you
would see an increase in funding that
way so I think it does include that
um in in our projections and so I think
that an attempt was made to try to uh
solve that issue that you that you bring
up
uh just a second Mickey if we took the
uh
equalized value of what and instead of F
and R numbers
in the governor's formula
I mean I'm asking you both instead of
using the fnr forms that are turned in
for the count we use the valuation per
student
if you follow me
I'll I'll give Adam first crack because
there's f r is in a couple different
spots in the point so I'll let Adam take
first crack so on the left hand side of
the formula we have fnr and that and
that gives a set amount to every uh
school who has fnr students So based on
the the the enrollment there and then on
the right hand side of the formula under
our proposal we have extraordinary needs
grants which basically takes the
property valuation of the equalized
valuation in each town and accounts for
that and accounts for the number of f r
students and targets Aid in that way and
so over time uh extraordinary needs
grants increase uh 50 every two years in
in our proposal and so that was our way
of okay saying okay stabilization's
phasing out
um that is it's based on Antiquated data
but we recognize that there are going to
be towns out there that will need
additional funding who who are I
I guess we would refer them as the
neediest communities and that's where
that Aid is targeted and we think it's
it's the most efficient way to Target
that Aid
um
over over the long term
yeah were you were you suggesting
replacing fnr with something that was
more based on equalized valuation for
people so that's straight up that I
think I mean
on the right side of the formula
certainly so that's where fiscal
capacity disparity Aid is so that's
equalized valuation per pupil paid a
grant per pupil no fnr is part of that
formula uh but you do have 70 plus
million dollars in the cost of an
adequate education relative to f r
counts I don't know what data set we
could replace that with
right off the top of my head unless you
did some sort of proration of valuation
and State against total pupils or
something or if you took Medicaid
students which we've got per town I
don't know Mark can probably speak to
the validity of the data so we do have
some data I think as of uh one July 22
as far as by Town ages 15 to 18 year old
Medicaid precipit or uh
members I don't know what the right term
is I'm not division three
um enrolled and we can apply that as a
you know as a each town as a percentage
of State total and apply that to ADM but
I would defer to mark because we won't
have really any sort of uniquely
identifiable data even with a direct
cert for a couple years
so as far as the left side of the
formula we haven't brought up the
lawsuits in the Constitution yet but the
left side of the formula is is what's
under litigation so if you were to so
what the governor's proposed is
increasing the left side of the formula
so that doesn't really create a legal
liability since we've increased it if
you were to decrease substantially from
the left side
um that would increase our legal
exposure so I so and I know you're not
proposing that
um so just something to consider when
you're when you're working with the left
side it's always a little dicey in a
sense that I know you're not considering
that so but the the I think what you're
talking about is taking the fnr holding
that is basically a hold harmless you're
guaranteed your F and R numbers if what
we could do is if your Medicaid numbers
out of town level happen to be higher
for a community
you'll be paid those instead right and
and ballpark I don't think I've ran that
but
that would basically be like bringing in
Medicaid direct cert now
um but not matching it to students and
not feeding kids so what that would cost
is approximately over 22 million dollars
but you would need legislation to do
that and that legislation would have to
be detailed and described how DHHS is
going to give us that data what is the
snapshot of their data are they going to
use pre-pandemic data which would cost
around 22 million dollars are they going
to use current data which would cost
more like
42 million dollars so that's that's the
challenge as far as you'd have to just
you design a new Grant which would need
new hp2 language which would need to be
implemented
okay
just to speak to that point
um it's something that I've taken quite
a bit of Mickey's time of uh over uh in
the last few weeks and um
I genuinely do not think we will have
the time to research it properly by the
time we gotta finalize the budget
which pains me greatly because it is
something that I think is in dire need
of addressing
um and I just don't know exactly how to
move forward because if I say the word
we should study it that's used to mean
something entirely different in a lot of
places but
I think we need to find a way to keep
working on this while recognizing that
we may just not have the time to address
it this cycle which again I'm very
unhappy about because it's something
that really bothers me
for now I will say that the proposed
Governor budget because they do change a
lot of stuff on the right hand of the
formula and they put quite a bit of
money there that tends to be allocated
in different ways so it will hedge
against some of those losses by towns
that have artificially low F and R
numbers the problem right now if we use
current Medicaid numbers which was
brought up the number would be higher it
would be higher because people haven't
been allowed to draw people off the
Medicaid so now those are inflated so
now we have fnr numbers that are under
counted and Medicaid enrollment that's
over counted go figure
right so I just I
I hate saying that I don't think we have
time to uh deal with that in this budget
cycle and we may want to stick to doing
fnr and finding an official or
unofficial way to continue working on
that to have some really good models
to drive future policy decisions on but
I just to to that point
three covet numbers
have a ratio of the student population
that are on Medicaid
I mean that ratio could be used against
current current student populations that
takes covet out of the equation
you follow me
so let's say School District had 100
students six percent or Medicaid
recipients we'll use six percent of the
population now for SNR
f r if that's not
I don't think that's going to do it
because it uh you know like Farmington
has a close to 50 percent you know it's
it's less than 50 percent but it's it's
in an area and six percent is I just
made that up oh okay I'm sorry no I just
made it no no but I'm your number would
come out to 50 right well it's whatever
that's all I'm saying is creating a
factor that can be used as an estimate
for this in the short term so so if you
want to make it a block grant that would
be very budget controlled
um
otherwise you set a dollar amount you
would like to allocate in that
methodology but to
to mix it with f and r
so in that situation take the Medicaid
you have Medicaid say you have um the
Medicaid data we have isn't just
students it's it's students in district
schools the students 5 through 18 uh uh
or participants five through eighteen
they could be in a charter school they
could be in an EFA they could be
homeschooled um so you take that number
and then you would apply it against a
district school base so it's going to be
kind of a higher percentage because in
the numerator you're including students
that are not necessarily in the
denominator so it's going to be a high
percentage but you could apply that
percentage
um
and then
I haven't run the numbers for that but
it's it's going to cost money more money
than currently I just don't know how
much because you would never want to
if a student if there's we have
information that there's an fnr student
in a school we would never want to fund
them less than that
um of course currently so it's going to
be an add-on it's going to be a Max
formula where you either get your
minimum F and R numbers you're holding
or this new Medicaid percentage number
so I have not run the numbers on that I
imagine it would cost multi-million
dollars so but it would be one way to to
Target Aid based on Medicaid population
similar to Target a based on property
values and targeting a based on F R
numbers targeting Aid so it's another
vehicle to Target Aid another data set
we can use
um I just don't have any language or
numbers in front of you right now sure
this is some data that I have worked
with and done the a greater than a
Medicaid or fnr type of idea okay uh I
think I think the numbers part of it
isn't that hard to run the calculation I
think the hardest part and this is where
I'm going to defer back to Mark is
how we would Define that data I don't
know like how easy would you say it is
to legislate doing what this discussion
is talking about as far as
anything's possible uh the decision
you'd have to make let me rephrase that
between now and Tuesday uh so I'd have
to go back back to my office
um yeah I I
the the every time you do something
rushed there's the probability that a
huge error will occur so
um we could get it done but there's a
high risk of an error occurring but the
date I'm sorry to take over the
questions here and uh is that data
definable like what Medicaid has shared
with you
or is that so I basically when we got
the data from Medicaid we said
give us the data
so that it best replicates the fnr data
and then they ran a query I did not know
I don't know the parameters that they
plugged in to run their query so you
could it would be fungible in a sense
that uh we would the law would have to
say or the legislation would have to say
it is the intent of uh the department of
Health and Human Services shall query
their DHHS data with the best intent of
it'd be squishy best intent of
satisfying the f r data set and then
you'd want to choose important time
snapshot and that snapshot either
pre-covered or after coveted um probably
a frozen snapshot is what you'd want to
do to really make it less squishy
oh
just a quick comment on the Frozen
snapshot every year that goes by its
poorer quality data I mean we really
don't have an ideal solution right now
because the pre-covy data is Old Town
has changed those percentages change
people do better people do worse you
know God knows and by the way the impact
of Kobe is very real towns that may have
been in good shape Rico it may not be in
that great of a shape right now and we'd
be measuring them based on how well they
were doing before covet current Medicaid
numbers inflated because no Dropout
current fnrm are numbers you know
understated because of I mean right now
three days
I have no suggestion on how we can do
something by Tuesday it's just first
time from here on about Solutions
yeah not state
you gotta push forward
it's kind of a joke I was gonna tell
Mickey I'm skiing in Vermont this
weekend so so it's very unlikely though
maybe I'll bring my computer
so that so that I guess that's that's my
pitch for the Governor's proposal I
think uh yeah I think it accomplishes
pretty pretty close to what you're
trying to accomplish if you also include
Medicaid direct certification in it
because in 2026 that'll kick in
um yeah I can't speak to how long it
would take to draft legislation on on uh
you know using Medicaid numbers instead
of f r uh and all of that
um but but you know interested to if
that that's a direction that the
committee wants to move in open to open
that discussion for sure
um
I got some data back in the office I
asked researcher upstairs to do some of
the following of these high school kids
and in terms of f r
and we're seeing that between our
freshmen and our sophomores there's a 10
drop with Juniors and seniors why can't
we not then take a an average of the
freshman sophomore year and apply that
to the other side this uh the uh junior
and seniors that would certainly Elevate
you know the f r a little bit if we're
talking f r what about K-8 k for through
eight are higher than the first two
years of high school
uh there's a higher percentage you see
your drop-off occur significantly when
they go into their junior year okay
yeah even that that's been forever
that's not a coveted thing right
okay
other than defining the problem what
whether the system would go with the
governor's plan since it takes into
account a lot of what we were talking
about
I mean respectfully
um
I am personally uh in my based on my
constituents request I am personally
closer to the proposal number one than
to the governor's recommended I think
that
um you know when I'm looking at the list
of the towns that do best under the
governor's proposal I'm noticing towns
like my own Hanover and Bedford who are
already doing really well but when I
compare you know how under the
governor's proposal
um Berlin is doing I I realize that
there is more work that could be done to
help those you know more needy
communities and I think that
um you know while we can message the win
of the increase based under proposal
number one and Target
um more direct Aid to the needier tones
or the the more um vulnerable towns I
think that in those districts I think
that that's just
more of my personal mission today and
um I would like to see possibly some
more tweaking of proposal number one
um as opposed to going completely with
just cutting off stabilization I think
that the net result of cut completely
repealing stabilization is not replaced
by this hold harmless clause and not com
um in this like gradual phase out over
time while increasing you know the the
um the other components like the
extraordinary needs Grant I think you
know if I'm looking at the overall
picture we haven't reached
uh the more equitable distribution that
we're trying to achieve so um my my vote
if it came down to that Governor
proposal or proposal number one it would
definitely be proposal number one at
this point I couldn't support the
governor's
plan as is I think we can do better than
that I think we we've already discussed
how we can do better than that so that's
my opinion
right uh question uh
representative Hank and Phillips uh
would you increase that to 4100 for
basic under that
under uh one yeah and I'm inclined to
say it's possible to do more I'd like to
see Mickey run another tweak of proposal
number one to see what that would look
like I think we can do better yeah yeah
okay I'm good with that
at this point in time the best spot in
my opinion is to continue with the
formulas and structure of proposed by
the governor but I do agree that moving
some money from the left to the right
side an amount of money to be estimated
leaving the bottom line
the same or maybe adjusting it depending
we still don't know exactly how much
money we have available yet but
well I know for this proposal I'm
talking about the overall division two
budget and whether we need to find some
savings somewhere but while we talk
about this I would leave the bottom line
untouched and I would you know again
estimate a couple of those things the
one thing that I want to express a
concern for is again the left side of
the formula has a legal liability side
to it so I would like to see some
significant increases in there to make
sure that we have less exposure I
believe the comment was that if we would
cut the funding on the left side we may
see liability I just wanted to ask were
you talking about cutting it from its
current value or from the proposed
Governor's values in the past there's
been cases there is the Dover case in
2016 where students based multiple
communities joined over and they sued
the state and were successful because
there was a cap on how quickly your
students can grow we would have joined
that lawsuit if there was a need to yes
so some communities had a lot of growth
in student student growth but the
legislature had a law that said your
growth is capped at x amount and they
basically kept what is a constitutional
education as defined by the state and
the court said that is unconstitutional
so there's ways to Tinker with the left
side that probably increases your legal
liability and has no legal or has
minimal legal liability but yeah that's
just a factor to always think about but
basically decreasing from the governor's
number while still increasing
significantly from the current number
should put us in a good legal situation
yeah increasing increasing above current
law is likely not going to increase your
legal liability it shouldn't
um now the third right grade readings
out so that is a decrease on the left
side so that's more than compensated
if you're thrown in base
yeah I think it's it's hard to say what
a judge would say or the litigation's
gonna go and go
one last follow-up
um if any drops because of the removal
of the third grade are more than made up
by the uh you know base adequacy
you are saying that that should put us
in a better place than we are today
legal liability wise yeah I'm not a I'm
not a Supreme Court Justice so I can't
answer that with authority of course
um but um but yeah I think that's a
general Paradigm in which to view the
the funding formula that if you're taken
away from here but you've more than more
than equaled it on in the same in the
same side of the formula the
Constitutional side of the formula
you're definitely fine or you should be
fine
um the also um the amendments in hp2 it
removes third grade reading as a
component of the cost of an adequate
education so it takes it out
um takes out the funding but also makes
out takes it out as part of the building
blocks of adequacy so how the courts
want to interpret that I don't know God
knows yeah but they'll probably go it's
a decision of the legislature that this
is not part of a constitutional adequate
education anymore and it's been taken
out so they'll probably view it as
understate law it's not a liability
anymore pretty appreciate it thank you
Mary thank you do you think it's
possible that we could hear from
occasion um a chair lad and um ranking
member uh Vice ranking member uh luno
they've been really
um involved in this quite a bit and they
might have some input I'd love to hear
what they have to say
I I just quite frankly we the equity
thing is disturbing just going with the
it would take 10 years to get where they
want to get which I think is marvelous
but that's a long time for taxpayers
since I haven't had a chance to say
anything
um I'm Mel Myler and I from Merrimack 9
and I'm the ranking Dem
uh Rick and I frankly have been working
on this
for a number of years we are both on the
uh Commission in 2018
about looked at this and from that
several of us thought that the umberger
review of that summer did not go far
enough and we then created the school
funding commission at which time
representative luno basically came in
and shared that
and so I just want to comment uh as I've
been listening to this I'm very
encouraged
by the conversation
one of the things that we've been trying
to deal with for some time is how do you
begin to Target Aid into those schools
that are are really in need
your conversations today has basically
given me hope that maybe we're going
there this time back to representative
Petrie's concern when he raised the
issue of donor towns Etc
one of the things we found in the
commission that really was a guiding
principle for us
was to look not at my kid my students
but our children
and as we begin to look at how do we
create a strong Workforce across the
state not just in those wealthy towns
but across the state
to help those districts that need
additional funding that can provide a
greater Equity of the opportunity for
kids particularly in those areas that
are that are impo that are underserved
that are impoverished this does
help and I think the conversations about
at least that I'm hearing from you that
the our kids looking at all of our kids
uh has been a at least from my
perspective a very important shiblet as
we look at school funding so I want to
compliment you for that I know you still
have got more work to do but it seems to
me that the philosophic issue of how do
we deal with all of this with our
children in schools is very important I
just wanted to make that comment I'm not
a numbers guy
these guys are the numbers guys but I
try to provide a philosophical look at
how we begin to move forward and I'm
very pleased with that and thank you Mr
chair for allowing me at least to sure
make those comments
tonight
thank you and I'll invite Dave up here
um I I concur that you have to do
something with the left-hand side we
have two court cases coming against us
right now
um and uh
I think we need to get by this somehow
and continue to try to get by it so
increasing base is important however to
the degree perhaps that I I've seen come
forward from the on the governor's side
I would I would take some of that and
maybe put some of it
um still on that side of the formula I I
I've spoken before about
um special education differentiated
eight
there's a place where 14 million dollars
would significantly if we use that
weighted formula of the three weighted
categories and doe has that information
it's something that just we have to do
legislatively and it'll happen
so that's one way of of keeping some on
the left hand side I'm also
reflective of everything we did in the
commission study in in the umberger
report stabilization has to go now how
fast we get it you know I agree with you
Mr chairman that
um we we need to do that but you know if
we spread it over so many years future
legislators are going to go after that
again and we're going to lose it
so I the shorter period of time we can
do it and make this thing work is better
um whether we can do it in seven years I
don't know
um that would be a decrease of what
around 15 percent
annually
um I think that should be a Target
um and um I'm really oppositional to
having
the extraordinary needs with you know we
have 17.5 million there or what nine and
then we 14.9 elsewhere in in the relief
um that's all got to stop we've got to
have one area and I I agree the
extraordinary needs is the best place
and how we work that working with
physical capacity Spirit Aid as well in
there
um
I would I would suggest that
um there must be a blending of the the
the two reports you got here where we
can have that third one as the blend and
and somehow attract that but you've got
to leave it some on that left-hand side
or we're going to be back in the
courtroom and we're going you know we're
going to have the man across the street
trying to spend more our money in
defense of what we have done as a state
and I I know we can avoid that if we're
a little bit more careful when we plug
it there I do know that that's and you
know that by putting more there you're
you're strengthening the position of the
wealthy community and the the poorer
committee at towns and we're not
necessarily striking out and hitting the
poor ones the way we need on the right
hand side so you got to find that that
comfortable area and I think it's that
third report somehow
represent little you might have
something sure sure thank you very much
representative Ladd and thank you very
much members of the committee Mr chair
um I I too agree with everything
Representatives Miler and Ladd uh have
said with regards to
um being here and and hearing the the uh
the conversation the discussion and the
excellent questions all day
um I I think it really shows an
incredible
um interest on the part of um of
division two and the finance committee
uh and the governor's office to um to to
to to do something meaningful for um for
public school funding across the state
uh I also am I'm am really
um it's refreshing to to hear the
comments that that you've all made that
really
um uh reflect I think the discipline
that you're all using in terms of not
opening up a spreadsheet and going right
down to the town you live in but uh but
looking at what what it's doing to our
to our most vulnerable and I know that's
an overused word but communities with
with
um lots of students from low-income
families
um lots of students in general and lots
of students from places with low
property valuations so um so obviously
our our largest cities come to mind
um you know first there but all also a
lot of our towns and um and and I think
the the one thing that really jumps out
for me from uh from this morning in the
in this afternoon's conversation
someone used the term happy medium
um and and it may be that that that is
what we're uh we're looking for here
something that as representative
representative Ladd said strikes that
balance of of of
um accomplishing some of the the goals
that we all agree on that we need to be
uh tapering up we need to be whittling
away
um stabilization maybe with maybe
chopping away uh stabilization
um but uh as as Mr landrigan said that's
really hard to do and um uh you know in
in in trying to make sure that that uh
that some of the the districts that have
the
lowest property valuations the highest
pockets of poverty and the highest tax
rates in the state so thinking Berlin
thinking Newport that they don't get
um you know that they don't get hurt and
uh and so uh so I I think I think there
is an opportunity for for a a happy
medium type type proposal that
accomplishes what the governor is
looking to do with um moving us away
from the the crutch of stabilization
um increasing uh the uh the base cost of
adequacy so the cost of the goods in the
bag and um and and making sure that
we're providing some relief for um for
well let me say the other way relief for
students in terms of you know better
outcomes and relief from taxpayers in
terms of skyrocketing property tax rates
and um
um and and I think we can we can do it
pretty close staying within the um the
the cost
um uh framework that that the governor
uh has has put forward uh the house a
few weeks ago did pass you know the the
education committee unanimously the
house on a Voice vote Hospital 529 which
has been referred to a few times here
which which
um I think touches just about I mean not
it doesn't necessarily touch touch some
of the wealthiest property wealthiest
students but it certainly touch touches
many of those and so many
um municipalities across across the
state and um and you know I think if
something like that was uh was was maybe
used in conjunction with a and and Mr
landergan has it um in The Proposal here
uh but um but maybe um maybe you know
step you know stepping up the force on
on that
we might be able to see a distribution
that's really good for good for places
like Manchester and Nashua but also good
for the some of the smaller
districts and towns that are really
struggling too and I appreciate the
comments from uh from um uh Hanover
Windham and and Newcastle uh with
respect to how they you know their
responsibility that that they see
um Statewide so thank you
I think that was the intent of trying to
get some 529 in this
but we actually retained it
say thank you I want to thank Mickey and
I hope his children will still recognize
him when this is over and for going well
above and beyond and any other cycle and
to add to that
um I'd like to to get a broader picture
of how these things how things go up and
down if you push one lever and the other
lever uh my grandson has that trait from
me too I do believe if we could get a
scheme if we moved as um representative
Higgins has suggested the 4100 and also
one for 4200
um to see how that plays out towards the
end and if it's also possible to raise
the um around the sped just I mean it's
a small amount but to 2100 for you know
for both years so that's like four
spreadsheets with four different
variables in there is that reasonable to
ask or are you just going to jump out
the window or throw me out the window
foreign so running these are not overly
difficult presenting them back to you
will be a little difficult with
production and getting it and that makes
sense I think one of the biggest
variables and then backing going back
from there is how much you're looking to
spend in total to make sure your
budget's balance your education trust
fund has the resources to cover a plan
how much do you want to allocate to Ed
funding and then we can maybe work
backwards in the components to fit into
that total spend and that's where I
think we were going earlier with kind of
look at the education trust fund with
where you are with your decisions to
this point but but certainly I can give
you a couple you know a menu or you know
a cafeteria whatever they call there's
like a chain a term for this and give
you some more options for for next week
I don't think I'm going to be able to
get this into a usable you know for
folks to work over the weekend anything
like that but I am happy to sit with
folks and I've done this in the past a
smaller group and run numbers kind of as
we're going to see if we can make
something work too
um
so
that's kind of where I'm at with with
this
we're looking for a sweet spot we're not
going to find it but we're looking for
something that kind of at least hits all
parts of the Target and I think you can
get there
and for me it's I'm spinning my wheels
without knowing how much of that total
on the far right column can that equal
and that's what I think once you solve
that I can give you a little bit and
over here with the governor's approach
give you a little bit here with 529 and
targeted and present some options in the
middle
oh
the trust fund is not necessarily an
increase in budget spending
I'm asking a question I'm not making a
statement
so if we flip to that page six of the
this packet the our usual tracking
sheets packet 96 million and folks I'm
sorry you probably don't have one of
these here
the tracking documents
we're all set if you're all set
well I gotta I got a question for
representative Ladd all right yeah it's
the same as if I may
core and and actually uh representative
Murray hit on this too
how much of a correlation is it between
the percentage of sped and poverty the
minute as a measure of poverty
special education whether you have TBI
traumatic brain injury or orthopedically
handicapped or a speech you know if
there was that everybody in Boston would
have an IEP
so there is no no relationship there
there's there is a relationship of
course when we're looking at overall
achievement and a poverty yes that there
that is definitely identified
so if you're looking at trying to
increase our our growth and our
achievement levels within the state then
you have to direct the money to where
it's best needed and that's with those
districts which are hurting
but there's nothing there the the reason
why I've mentioned special education and
are differentiated before because you
know and I know that we have children
that are very expansive in terms of
providing a service in the first seventy
thousand dollars is that of the school
district now if we Elevate the amount
we're getting in differentiated Aid
which we know that you can't deliver
some of these services at the pricing
that we're providing under special ed so
that helps offer some rationale for
those that are looking at what's our
commitment to that left-hand side of the
formula we're putting some dollars there
where it's necessary we start the
weighted formula and then we in future
years we see how this works and maybe
even build upon it
there is a definite need as expressed by
the 39 States in this country that do
that right now
and it's it's difficult for me to
comprehend why we're funding all the
differentiated AIDS special ed kids with
one figure only when we have 13
different IEPs which are significantly
different from each other
so so you're saying we should put more
money in a special ed in the
differentiated Aid should we should we
step it within within the spread uh you
you have the flexibility the primary
goal that we have in in education policy
right now is for all to recognize that
there should be weighted components
within differentiated Aid now we started
at two thousand dollars plus basically
that's what we're at and we multiplied
it by two and then by three to get to
those other categories uh you you could
you could multiply it a little lower uh
I hope not a great deal because we're
not really putting in significant
dollars when we talk about our whole
budget for Education when we're talking
perhaps 15 million dollars or at most at
Max it'd be around 22.
but there is some fudge room there as
we've been talking about with base
adequacy and that and and on the right
hand side so it's finding that sweet
spot as I've heard people talking about
I think you'll get there
I just wanted to
representative Vlad addressed it very
well but I just want to reinforce that I
don't think there is any correlation
between poverty and special education
needs if anything sometimes that provide
really good Services end up attracting
families to move over because the
schools will properly handle their kids
so if we look into one it may be even be
reverse but I don't think there is
enough of a variation to consider that
part of the policy I agree with
representative land that if we want to
handle that we got to look at the costs
not the percentages of students or
anything okay
well and if if I may uh in the past we
have a matter of fact uh my first term
there was two students from Nashua
schools it was 750 000 a piece and
that's you know the weighted formula
that representative Ladd talked about
was uh
you know that's
maybe we should look at stepping that
special ed you know right for where it's
neat or or either that or if there is
you know catastrophic a like that maybe
changing that a little bit
I mean Now's the Time well well we're
there's nobody to hand the ball to we're
it
well that's that's the whole thing here
trying to mix
what
what can ask representative Murray
to basically that and that's it sure
um
so is this is this document give us an
outline of what's left on the left side
and what's on the right side that's what
it says here
as a blueprint uh yeah I think uh doe
put that together to kind of break out
the components of the formula
yes right
this this has just the
um the figures for 2024.
right on the on the right hand side when
we keep talking about the right hand
side what's over here is additional
Grant relief Aid extraordinary needs
stabilization and hold harmless is that
yep is that the right side yes thank you
okay so on page six of the education
trust fund online 22 is where you'll see
the line that ties to this whole
discussion that we're talking about so
that the amounts that are carried in
there now for division two's places the
governors so
um and that was approximately the same
as the other proposal that was the idea
was to stay around the same number so
if if we did add additional funds in
this area those appropriation amounts
would increase and of course it would
decrease your ending position so as you
stand right now with the revenue
projections with the house bill 2
provision relative to the uh
uh swap of uh split of business taxes
and some of the other decisions we've
made to this point there's 96 million
dollars remaining at the in the
education trust fund at the end of June
30 2025.
I can leave it with that or uh I don't
know if there's any questions to that
point how does that correlate to uh this
third call is that
are they that's this is the governor's
numbers well these the governors they're
approximately the same it's it's
approximately the same
but if we if we increase it to 4 100 or
4200 that all that's going to do is eat
into the fund and that's and that's the
question is do you want to increase
those numbers to something else which
would eat into the fund yes it would
change your bottom line but that would
give flexibility with coming up with
this I'm going to use it again The Sweet
Spot you know the the third uh sheet
that you want me to work on which I can
do
I'm I think I'm misunderstanding
something doesn't page six and the 96
million in Surplus reflect
um
the governor's proposal
um so I mean changing our formula you
know to 41
um
and using the rest of that money on the
other side of the formula won't change
the 96 million if we're working within
the governor's budget we're still left
with a 96 million every well this is
where I'm confused because I'm hearing
two different The Proposal I walked
through today stayed within that but
we're discussing now adding to it so
that's that's where my my question is if
you wanted to spend more in total than
the governor that's the line it would be
reflected my second point is that you
know we have we are facing
um the situation where we have and
surplus in the education trust fund it
appears as Surplus may continue you know
no one's going to predict the economy
but um it seems like it would be very
appropriate use of the education trust
fund to use it for education and worry
less about moving it to the general fund
for other programs
no no but I'm saying there's a proposal
to change what's going into the
education trust fund and I'm saying
maybe that's not necessarily a good
thing to do because it seems better are
used for the education trust fund money
is the education that's my thought and
that's why I said but to the point of
why is it decreasing every 100 dollars
you add to the base is 16 million
so if we had three in
ches
and and like I said that there may be
netting associated with depending on
which plan you use so if you go from the
governor's plan
and increase 100 on the base you might
not see a 16 million on the other end
because it may chip into the hold
harmless that's required so there's
going to be some netting involved in
that 48 million but the point is we're
going to spend the money we were holding
on to for education
distributed differently a little more
aggressively to the media communities
than the even the governor's plan but
can I still I'm still feeling that
there's a disconnect and maybe it's
probably mine but this 96 million is
reflective of what's left after the
governor's budget what we're proposing
is to stay right now what we're
proposing is a hybrid system where we
stay within the governor's budget so
there would still be the 96 million
that's what the proposal one is yeah
staying with them so that leaves us 96
million to pull 20 million or whatever
additional to Target every time you add
a hundred dollars to the 3 900 it costs
16 million dollars in the budget yes but
that's not I guess I'm not being clear
um
yes
um I get that maybe you can tell because
I'm not doing it
um you're doing great keep it up you
know um
staying within the governor's budget
still would leave us regardless of how
we hybrid it out with moving up to 41
and moving stay or moving this to
keeping it 47 and keeping maintaining
the governor's budget we still will have
96 if we stay within those parameters we
still have 96 million in Surplus that we
can tap into to increase the targeted
age beyond what the governor's budget is
proposing and Beyond what we're
proposing within the governor's
parameters does that make sense am I on
the right track here
yeah
just because we could and I agree that
we could it doesn't necessarily mean
that we should but I do acknowledge that
we could do that
when you're saying add 11 on what are
you saying 1100 no no I'm saying
right now
proposal one yeah stays with it within
the governor's parameters
but
I would prefer that the base in proposal
one become proposal 2 move to some
higher number
4100 4200
but every time we do that we're reducing
the bottom line on page six by 16
million dollars per hundred that's 48
that we're taking half of it so it
depends if uh it depends which plan you
use so if we let's say we started with
the governor's budget that doesn't have
the any of the targeted Aid except for
the extraordinary needs in its current
form and the big hold harmless if you
increase that by
you know from 3 900 to something you're
going to reduce the whole harmless
that's required so it's not going to be
a 16 million dollar increase okay but
whatever it comes out
some number so
yes
we're eating our seed for no
this isn't Seed corn this is this is
extra
so I guess a question I have for the
committee is we've heard from all about
all I'm going to say four including
stabilization is
stabilization out completely or is there
any sort of appetite to phase it in any
way because that will drive a lot of
this calculation as well
I think I think
the point that it's even cold
stabilization is the problem
if we could call it XYZ or something
else
uh but as long as it's calculated in
here
next term they can decide oh we're going
to put it back and not reduce it I think
your idea of reducing it
is good
but if we reduced it by 15 percent
instead of five
what does that do and that's a question
I have for the committee is there is
that an option to do because we've heard
I think the consensus is
stabilization is old and the idea is to
get rid of it at some point but is the
intent to go all or nothing or is there
room for phase out of that
Mary yeah you've been playing this game
the longest
well it's such a drastic change if we
could go maybe with like 15 percent
and keep 15 and reduce the rest
and
then the following year we'll reduce It
Again by another five percent so it
would really be gone in three years
but just I just feel like by taking it
all away immediately
um makes it very difficult well Mickey's
proposal was to take it out of 20 over
20 years
not representative Ladd said something
about 15 a year
so it was a seven year fall off right
okay
well no I'm happy with 15 percent
what how would you make that up
when you say make it up like keep it in
the formula how would I make it that's a
reducer by 15 a year
what does that do
please when I first arrived here
we didn't have stabilization but we did
have 27 million there in terms of hold
harmless
so if you were to get rid of your
stabilization you're probably going to
have to end up with some hold harmless
somewhere along the way here
um and you may be calling a different
name well maybe still the same animal
but it's a hold harmless is certainly
curious a different connotation
with all of us than than uh
if we call it hold harmless
and but it doesn't it doesn't
cap itself like the governor's version
well the governor's trying to get rid of
stabilization I I understand that's a
good move I'm just changing the name
yeah okay because that's all he all he
did was change the name but it changed
the criteria the calculation criteria so
two versions of hold Timeless whole time
was born in whole time was too
we really mean old harmless this time so
what we did what we did was because we
increased the base in the fnr it reduced
the need for for some towns to have
their stabilization right and so
um it made it so that the whole harmless
was 87 million rather than
um
156 million whatever it is now
um so when you if you're looking to
increase bass in F and R in the left
side of the formula you're going to need
less for stabilization hold harmless or
stabilization whatever you're calling it
um so
that's that when you add stuff on one
side it affects the other side so that's
I'll that's all I'm saying on that
um
so
regardless of what you call it I we call
it a whole harmless but that's
um I guess would you have to consider
who benefits by keeping it in there
because that that's where your fight
will be and and you'll do all this and
you'll end up not getting any of it
no
it's not what I was what I was trying to
say was that
you have to consider who benefits by
keeping the formula in there
because they'll be the ones that will
stop you from doing what you're trying
to do
I don't know I guess I made I guess I
think you're saying that this requires
some sophisticated messaging
stabilization hold harmless is all is
it's all political
money it's it that has no cost there's
no cost so this is I think I can answer
your question so stabilization grants
are based on Antiquated data it's 2006
2006 data the that was funded in 2012.
right
we're eliminating that in the governor's
proposal and we're providing a whole
harmless of 87 million because we're
also increasing base and fnr and when
you do that some towns receive
extra funding whereas it reduces the
need for state for for a whole harmless
and so
what we're fundamentally doing is we're
correcting the formula going into the
future where we're not using old data
anymore we're we're and we're phasing
out that hold harmless in favor of other
targeted uh pieces of Aid and so you're
no longer it solves the problem of no of
using old Antiquated data I think that
was that was the main driver behind that
thank you
if I could just add one important
element
the reason why we still have a hold
harmless is to make sure that nobody
loses a dollar as a result of us
eliminated stabilization people are just
gonna wait until the new formula catches
up with them and then they'll join the
rest of the crowd in uh you know
starting to increase but until that
happens they will have to wait until
everybody catches up with them but
nobody loses a dollar because the major
concern about removing stabilization is
that towns have been budgeting based on
it and if we make a major cut suddenly
there will be a disruptive impact this
ensures that we get rid of stabilization
but there will never be that type of
impact and that's really the best way in
which we can do this it ain't perfect
there is still an imbalance for a while
until a formula catches up there is
always the risk that somebody in the
future may Tinker with it and make it
worse but as of now I genuinely see this
as the absolute best way in which we can
tackle this problem that we all know
needs to be solved so I would really
want to leave that as it is because I
think it's the best choice available
yes just a quick thank you Mr chair so
question Adam
um
your formula
takes 10 years correct to get to where
we want to be and that's more equitable
distribution of the formula across the
state
that's what we want
is there a way
to
collapse your formula into two years so
we achieve your goal in less time
I would I would add that
what you when you do that
um it may be a too quick of a very
expensive it would be very expensive
yeah and and it would reduce
stabilization so or or hold harmless so
quickly that some towns may lose a lot
of funding very quickly
um if that makes sense so I
I think maybe reducing the 10 years
maybe okay but I I don't I don't know
about a two-year phase out
excited
there's there's almost an infinite
amount of scenarios you can run in
variables you can put into the formula
but there's there's kind of two ways to
get rid of the stabilization there's the
um there's the governor's
proposal which basically gets rid of all
stabilization so 157 million dollars but
replaces it with a new hold harmless
Grant so he essentially got rid of
half of nearly half of the stabilization
but it's still there it's still there
and it just lives as a new Grant a whole
harmless Grant but to get rid of all the
stabilization in a two-year period you
can't do that without towns losing
significant amount of money which
creates budgeting problems and I don't
think this committee is interested in
that
um the other way to get rid of
stabilization is to hyper power charge
the other eight components so the point
where if you take stabilization away
they don't lose money that is likely
very expensive that would cost we're
talking hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars to to design a
formula that would be so powerful that
it would when you take away
stabilization no one would notice that
would be very expensive so we're back to
this this balancing act that we've been
trying to do here um all afternoon
um so there's two ways to get rid of
stabilization there's the governor's
proposal get rid of stabilization and
build the hold harmless and basically
it's kind of like a stabilization
renaming
um it's it's a different it functions
different than the current stabilization
and it's based on
it's just reduced stabilization then
there's the proposal one you saw
presented today where its stabilization
stays as is and it reduces five five
percent
proposal one
takes about a six seven million dollar
cut out of stabilization the governor's
proposal takes a more substantial cut
out of stabilization
um there's two ways to do it it's all
about timing you're not going to do this
and you're not going to get rid of state
legislatures but that's
kind of what you're dealing with right
now
and I'll just uh I'll just remind the
committee that I and you know we at one
point it was a four percent decrease and
then two years later it was it was put
back at 100
um that's similar to proposal one except
it's a 20 it's the 25 years it's 20
years
yeah
there is a huge difference between the
current stabilization grants which are
set to a dollar amount
and what we are doing here where we are
moving into the appropriate formula and
while the formula catches up with people
they by Design on a temporary basis
which is self-limiting and decreasing
itself every year
makes it go away and by the way all that
it takes for this to go away is for
people not to Tinker there is no there
is a huge difference between you know
the two approaches if we try to maintain
the stabilization Grant people will look
at just that part of the budget and say
oh my God this is the money I'm losing
every year and they will not pay
attention to the increases in the other
side the governor's proposal makes that
go away nobody loses money and there is
no stabilization Grant to look at and
say oh my God I'm losing money you just
decrease the amounts in the hold
harmless but not by losing money at any
time there is a significant difference
Mr chair if I could just follow up with
that I think most of your comments are
on point but your your conclusion that
no one is hurt by taking stabilization
away is wrong there are towns on paper
that we can see that will hurt
significantly by taking away
stabilization and only having the hold
harmless to support them there are towns
that will significantly be hurt could
you define hurt in this case because I'm
annually I want to make sure I
understand what you are saying because
the way the her that I'm thinking of and
I don't want to put words in your mouth
is that
they would not get as much money as they
would get if the same formula would be
applied without removing the
stabilization Grant is that what you are
talking about
if you just want to take a look at
Berlin in the in the two spreadsheets
you'll see they lose a lot of money
under the governor's proposal as
compared to the proposal number one the
stabilization is the key component of
propping up that loss so the hold
harmless while I agree with you in
intellectual functionality of getting
rid of the Antiquated situation under
the governor's proposal but it is not an
equal replacement the hold harmless is
not an equal replacement for these
property poor tones
I hear you
I agree with what you are saying in the
sense that those Towners will have a
lesser increase or a flat you know
hell you know State contribution
but very bluntly there is no other way
to get rid of the stabilization Grant
rather than you know
growing them a bit more slowly while
everybody else grows faster so that they
catch up I want to remind you that right
now they're getting that money you know
essentially unfair way because they are
getting way more help than they would
normally get if the data that we use was
current and that's really the unfairness
image that we are trying to address and
I think it is important to address it in
a way that does not lead to them losing
money but I don't think you can have
your you know cake and eat it too and
get rid of it but not decrease those I
mean you know I think this is the best
way to address this but yes it there is
they don't get the same increases that
they would get if this stabilization
wouldn't be removed
I know I know and I think Mickey's
waiting for a decision uh I I would
suggest 41 or 4200 base and uh go from
there
like you suggested here
if I may make a suggestion to
we can choose any any amount we want but
if we ask Mickey for just one number
right now
you know
we won't be able to tell how in a
slightly different scenario we may have
done better maybe maybe have a few
values
it's not a big thing to get one or two I
mean but you can see the shift right
that's all you're looking for you're
looking for the shift and give them some
direction because right now we're
spinning the wheels yeah I think and go
to what we need to do our work
um for Mickey and maybe our minds will
have a little chance to think a little
bit more and then
we'll also know if what kinds of money
we have left over
like a recess break or just a break okay
so so so for for me to I think come back
with the to the committee with you know
maybe it's five options or something I
think a couple locking down a couple
variables is important and get back to
that education trust fund we are winding
down our budget process here so not even
talking at funding anymore we have to
lock down our decisions on the budget so
there's still a couple of variables with
the education trust fund one being Ed
funding we talked about the other being
School building Aid we heard a lot about
that this morning there are a lot of
other the governor's budget does propose
a few new odds got quiet in here a few
other uh programs onto the education
trust fund and we've more or less
approved those
um by not we don't have any amendments
to do anything else to them so I don't
know if it makes sense Mr chair to
decide or at least discuss
what is the committee's intent how much
of a balance do you want to leave in the
education trust fund at the end of the
biennium and how much of it how much do
you want to spend and if so and which
programs because then if I knew for
instance looking at adequate education
Aid on line 22
if you are okay with increasing those 20
million a year for instance which would
reduce 40 million from your bottom line
then I can take that back and try to
come up with options that fit within
that budget number so that's I think
we're getting close to needing to settle
in on how much you want to spend in
total on Ed funding and then backing
into the formula
well my idea was 36 36 million but 40 is
just good
and can I suggest of you know about
backing in the other way education
funding is probably the most significant
thing that we're going to be doing and
to put that first and adding that money
into that and then if we need to back
out some other things we have approved
tentatively some other programs and
maybe you're saying in light of our
responsibility to the students of the
state we don't do this because we want
that money to go back in there and we
reduce the about or we don't reduce the
balance quite as much because it says
well we're not going to do this for 2
million would rather the 2 million go
into education funding as opposed to
this other program because we have
approved a few of the things which in
light of what I think is our primary
responsibility we might want to revisit
so I think you know I would be glad to
go to ask him to add the 36 or out of 40
million I'm good with that and I would
want to go I'd go backwards looking at
programs that we've already maybe sort
of approved and reconsidering that
because the education funding is our
most important job I think
now having said that
is related to
play with stabilization as opposed to
make whole
certainly so and this gets back to what
I was was saying before is would this
committee have an appetite to support
and funding plan that perhaps reduce
stabilization by 15 instead of five
versus five or a hundred percent yes so
if that's the case then I can that's
something I can work with and come back
with some sort of blending and we've
talked about this between the governor's
budget and that other proposal we walked
through today
can I follow up around that and maybe
you know someone can help me here
because it
um
it's almost a version of semantics that
instead of it being stabilization we're
going to call it hold harmless but
there's still an and the goal seems to
be the same is so can someone tell me
what's not that it's just a semantic
change we're just basically a sort of a
shell game or I think to Mickey's point
is there a way of achieving the end that
we want because yes the data was bad we
shouldn't be doing this anymore but
people will kind of freak out and says
oh my God stabilization is gone is there
a way of re-messaging it
um I think we all have the same goal but
I'm concerned about how this sounds to
people going out you know the the
knee-jerk reaction is how can you take
away stabilization and it's like wait
wait no you're going to be held home
harmless instead and it's almost it's
it's
yeah so I we need a way of messaging
this so people understand what the goal
is and why stabilization is problematic
well I can I think stabilization is
based on historical non-changeable
oh
I mean
[Music]
yes
156 million bucks came out of that
formula that was developed by The Joint
uh legislative committee for costing of
an opportunity for an education that was
Senator S Brooks deal
and we had a formula That Base adequacy
was what 3456 I believe it was uh and
then we also had a category called
differentiated age special education and
it was based upon percentages of kids
arrive at that had that qualified within
that municipality
and there were some really heavy weights
there for example the district you come
from Mary received significant because
you're well over the 48 percent mark
then another 100 100 million dollars was
taken from the fiscal capacity disparity
Aid that we once had in that formula
that's what we came up with this 150
million bucks now if you track back and
say where'd it come from and now you're
raising the base by this much you must
be able to get some kind of a ratio for
these categories to try to fit back in
some of these on the grant side and on
the left-hand side which is very
important now due to the court cases so
that's the historical background on it
I think the way the message is
stabilizations based on old data it's
Antiquated and the the hold harmless is
different because it's it's a lower
Grant amount only in that you are
increasing base and fnra to make up for
the difference and the whole harmless
phases out over time and so I think that
is the fundamental difference is once
based on old data one is fundamentally
looking into the future to try to
correct the formula and that's what
that's the way I would differ the two
so Mickey can we do what he just said
which part specifically there was a few
things said there I mean it sounds to me
like you're still going to have to we'll
call it hold harmless
instead of stabilization but they're
still going to have to be some some
funding
15 percent
well if you go up to 4 200 stabilization
will go down correct right not by much
but yeah well I mean but so this is the
difference that
stabilization we've known for years and
hold harmless as presented in House Bill
2 are two different things it over time
they they're two different things at the
at the time now it's exactly the same as
what stabilization was back in 2012. but
comparing them today is is tough to do
if you eliminate stabilization replace
withhold harmless
the additional Aid that you give to the
property poor town some of the
thoroughlands claremonts pittsfields it
the hold harmless brings them up to
current law
if you keep stabilization as we know it
in place then layer on some of this
additional stuff you give those towns
more money than current law and that's
the difference so it's it's a matter of
is it the policy of this committee to
give to Target additional Aid to certain
towns we and we've described them as
needy towns above what they would get if
you did nothing or do you want to change
the formula for this biennium bring them
up to what they would have received
under current law with the understanding
that this law is presented in the
governor's recommended budget would
change over 10 years and it would start
to reduce the whole harmless and
increase a targeted age so those are the
that's essentially what's before the
committee to decide and that's where
it's really hard to tweak the formula to
do everything that we've talked about
that I think folks want to do in one in
one swoop so if we if we take voice
stabilization then all the other
grants that we've given
they're only going to go up to current
law but if we keep stabilization they'll
get more than the current law
essentially what we thought we were
doing good
is negative and it depends it depends on
everyone has a different definition of
good right it's different policies so
some folks say that stabilization
existing is problematic because it's so
such old data and it shouldn't be in
there but once it's taken out now you
have to recognize that that hold
harmless just represents your new
calculated Grant plus a whole harmless
to bring them up to as if you did
nothing for this biennium I'm not
speaking to the O years just for this
budget if I may
describe this in a different way maybe
that would help
we have an old formula and stabilization
right now we have a new formula which
gives everybody more money
but between the old formula and
stabilization some towns were getting
even more than the new formula and
that's where the whole harmless comes in
right so nobody's losing the people who
were way over are still right there
and as over time we'll
this hold harmless will go away because
the formula will increase and keep
increasing until everybody is all caught
up we are never gonna give a town that
currently has stabilization less than
they would have gotten under this
formula we are giving them more until
they catch up with everybody
right we're giving them more through the
whole tournaments until the formula
catches up no that's not right no that's
the way it please correct me so that
that is true under 24 25 in a sense that
the hold harmless stays static it's not
static it stays in effect for 24 and 25
so basically Berlin Claremont right
those towns those big stabilization
towns
um Farmington they can't lose more than
current law because the hold harmless
holds them to current law under hb2 as
proposed by the governor there is a
phase out of the hold harmless oh right
so that is where that is that is where
though that is where you would lose more
money under current law is when the
whole harmless goes away but for 24-25
um I was describing 24 25 I appreciate
now I better understand what we were
talking about Earth so I
[Music]
considered problematic so I think if we
are going to do our job correctly
um and right if we're gonna do right for
the State of New Hampshire that we have
to acknowledge that current litigation
is happening because current law levels
are not at meeting the need and there's
real sufficient constitutional issues
so knowing that if this phase out were
to go into place we would be in this not
only the same position that we are in
now but in a worse position for some of
those towns and I think our job is to
put us in a better position for some of
those districts you know to to
reallocate in such a way that we are
less in less risk of you know finding a
court saying we did it wrong again so
this is our chance we have you know this
this balance in in the in the education
trust fund we can reallocate a little
bit of that money in such a way that
will put us in a better position to fend
off those charges and I you know this is
the time we have this money
we are talking about tweaking the
formula in such a way that it can help
these towns and and still increase the
base that some of the other towns are
also benefiting so I think you know this
is the moment let's seize it I think we
can solve a major problem here it's
gonna take some tweaking like Mickey
said but this is the opportunity I think
we should walk through that door
if I if I may ask were you the changes
that you are suggesting are you talking
about the moving of funds from the left
to the right side or what are the
changes that we were talking about you
were suggesting so you know we're
talking about the left side of the
equation for at least the adequate you
know at least increasing the base but
when we're also talking about the right
side I think we have to acknowledge if
you completely get rid of the
stabilization and only go with the whole
harmless phase out
we're not in a better position for these
property needy tones so we need to
consider heavy more heavily weighing the
right side of the equation even if we
tweak the the left side of the equation
so
I think it's important to understand
that under both these proposals there
are going to be some towns that I think
lose I lose money
um over over the life of the the plan
whether it's uh you know proposal one
there are going to be some towns that
lose money over the 20 years and under
um you know the other one it is it's
over 10 years
um
so I just I I do want to make that point
that's possible I I haven't run the
proposal one for 10 years
the only thing I'll say is the
components in the that proposal the
thresholds and the grand amounts have
the CPI the two percent applied to those
so
in theory they could keep up with the
pace of stabilization but uh I don't
know if that's for sure I haven't run
that that's true
yeah thank you Mickey did you say that
if we do away with the stabilization
that uh what we our proposal hybrid
system
um
there wouldn't be any increase on the
right hand side to the needier schools
or did I misunderstand that I thought
that we were trying to add money to the
right hand side but then I think you
said something we can do that you know
um that we couldn't do that by getting
rid of home um stabilization entirely or
can can you just go back over 100
reduction of stabilization I don't think
you can come up with a target a day that
would not require a hold harmless so it
wouldn't make any impact on the right
hand side which is it would make an
impact just not to 100 of the
communities for sure I I mean correct me
if I'm wrong I don't feel like not with
it would it go to the needier
communities
not probably to the extent that they'd
lose stabilization I think the loss of
stabilization would offset the targeted
eight
unless you spent a ton of money yeah
there's some there are some communities
that have such a large stabilization
grant that there's very it's very
difficult unless you're willing to spend
a lot of money
um to Eclipse that stabilization and so
there's there's there's almost
uh I think HP 701 which was the 2019
proposal that the um the house passed I
think had a similar got got rid of
stabilization I believe and got that
hold harmless down to 27 million and
they spent a significant amount of money
um then the Senate added restored
stabilization but basically no matter
how you target the aid and that that
formula used fiscal capacity disparity
Aid F and raid all that stuff and still
had a 27 million dollar hold harmless so
no matter what to keep people neutral
you need something like old harmless
we're also gonna have the town by town
is going to show negative balances
so it looks like stabilization or
do you do you think it would it be
possible to take like a 10 minute recess
that's a great idea
thank you
because my brain expanded yeah
yeah so let's take take cam we'll see if
20 actors she's about 300. one base
oh yeah simple yeah hey and that helps
stabilization at some point because
they're going to be getting more money
yeah you know
they may get more money this time but
eventually that's going to go
stabilization is going to go away
well because we're
foreign
let's let's address other things
Mickey's going to run some scenarios for
us so we'll Monday Monday morning will
be hard at it and I I think I think the
conclusion is that we're not going to
make everybody happy
so
the question how do we minimize the
unhappiness I think you know messaging
that everybody gets an increase and
messaging that we've made an honest
attempt to Target the poor communities
and you can show them the numbers I mean
you're right no not everyone's going to
be happy but messaging that overall
there's an increase for everybody and
there's an additional increase for those
who need it the most
okay yeah looking at item two
on on Page Six
uh no I line 23
as we decrease the
our the base
we have to increase the charter school
by the same amount
because there this this budget is based
on charter schools of getting nine
thousand dollars which includes the base
plus the additional Grant additional
Grant so if you want to flip to page 25
of this so this is representative
Mooney's Bill if you remember we had uh
House Bill 272 so on line eight of this
bill we've got 46.27 right so that's the
additional
Charter School Grant that's increased
under this bill I think what you're
referring to Mr chairs wherever we
settle on Ed funding or the cost of an
adequate education base amount plus this
you want it to be a nine grand right
okay so what I'll do is I'll hang on to
this amendment here and it's in here
kind of waiting in the wings to see what
we do with that funding
we will adjust
right to be to be uh the plug I guess to
get to 9000 or thereabouts so I've got
that tracked for us good thank you
and the net cost of that
will be uh we'll determine that you may
you may achieve some savings uh because
the governor's um
the governor's budget budgeted Charter
Schools up to forty seven hundred
dollars of the basis so depending if you
come down and the cost is so there's
going to be some netting involved but
I'll figure that out as time comes okay
do we need to look at any other items
here that are
um
School building Aid still we haven't
addressed that one we have not I don't
know if you want to do that now or move
on to anything I don't have a whole lot
else if you want to have that discussion
I think we ought to look at the uh
extraordinary needs is that the page
three
but I will add that uh some of those
items that we've already
decided
hb2 items that we discussed and thought
were okay
include the
um
there's four mil four and a half million
dollars for
computer science applications
okay
uh it's uh section 63 on page one of the
tracking sheets so that we're in House
Bill 2. oh yeah
I switched on you
we had we had several education items
uh one was the teacher of the year one
was
I'm trying to find them right now and my
eyes are kind of worried uh
so 62 yeah 62 through 65 or your
computer science related items on page
one of uh
the tracking sheets
yeah
I'm saying
there was something some of these items
were not asked for by the Departments
necessarily and so if we're if we're
looking for money I'm just I'm just
rehashing this a little bit some of
these items we could say uh
we need it for education or or somewhere
else okay
um
well we don't need to yet I I'm just
throwing things in the hopper here to
say this is a bridge we can cross
um
that's no that's no money there's I mean
there's two million for the Civics thing
that's not a lot but it's something
right
my point is if we if we if we need to
find money we'll go back and talk to the
commissioner say how much of this can we
borrow back
sort of sounded like
they did okay
confirmed
okay
um
I get I'm getting the same sense on item
on the top the interoperability lab
application
that was a man and a half dollars to
hire people in the short term
and I was I was thinking about that in
the shower this morning of all things
and I'm wondering if if this is like a
business Enterprise
are we the right funding agent no
um that's the question I asked myself I
heard of the answer uh
yeah
now you mean 100 million yeah
and if if they if they decide to do this
that's up to them
when the same thing uh
and then page four is the Whittemore
Center
Arena and Mary likes that
so we're going to keep that one in
all right yeah but that's a business
decision all right yes it's a business
I uh I did visit with Arena and you know
we were there and I agree there is a
need but given that we are starting
behind the eight ball with so much in
terms of Revenue frankly if there is
stuff that we do need to remove from an
education budget I would say that's one
of the
lesser priorities in terms of funding
because I'd rather you know deal with
teachers in front of kids and all that
necessary stuff so uh
will no need to you know decide anything
because we still don't have a clear
bottom line but I'm you know
that's a candidate
or are there any other of these items
that we need to get to any departments
back in for
because I'm looking at page page two
okay
and there's a lot of open items and we I
don't know if we've even addressed them
yet
like uh section 169
my understanding is public works and
highways is considering the second
project so the winner Squam is seven
million correct yeah in House Bill 25
but are not entertaining
uh Sugar River Hill which is so I don't
know if if the committee has heard
testimony on that we do have 12 and a
half million dollars factored into our
education funding schedule now for this
already if no one's proposing changes
you could probably be okay with that
section
can we agree on that one 12. no to leave
it in
it's not going to happen
Newport yeah in that same area
right
well plus if if if capital budget is
taking care of the other one would that
takes care of that problem
want to take them out
no no no no no well we I mean
right okay I am too so okay what about
the bottom two the change the revenue
distribution of the BPT and the bets
that impacts what's going to go into the
education trust fund
um we could adjust that and you know a
small adjustment can result in a
significant amount of money so I don't
even know I was my two
we can figure out look at what we're
doing now look at what the governor is
proposing in here and see if we're
comfortable with that or adjusting that
so we keep a little bit more money in
the education trust fund
okay what was the amount on that dude
it's about 73 million net between the
two that would go to the general fund
rather than the education trust fund per
year
so you'll see that on that uh schedule
on page six the education trust fund
schedule we went through earlier those
adjustments are carried there I would
just I would just remind you if if the
division does go that direction
obviously there'd be a general fund
Revenue hit you know that would be the
offset so
just to keep that in mind okay
I would like to keep that in because the
way we are doing it right now is that we
end up with more money in the education
fund that's limited and you know can
only be used for that while if money is
sent to the general fund nothing
prevents us from funding education
adequately by charging through the
general fund but there is no good reason
to just put more money into the
education than we spent so
need for that right now to try to do a
targeted schools there is a need for
using that money now and I'm going from
65 to 35 it's pretty hefty
Tom I have a question
um online on Section 169
where it says the changing of funding
for renovation and expansion of Career
and Technical programs from capital
budget to budget
I know but I didn't understand
there's some statutory changes where a
references capital budget and just
references budget process so that's what
is the house bill 2 change behind this
appropriation for this renovation
construction of the CT Center is in the
operating budget under uh or in House
Bill 2 rather from the education trust
fund versus House Bill 25 capital budget
right and is it
what is it is it is it a new building
renovation
of the CTE well that's that all goes
through capital budget doesn't it no
they they can't that's the that's the
historical process
I think the governor's office and Adam's
here to verify uh recognize there was
additional funds in the education trust
fund to use for this and that freed up
uh capital budget uh uses for other
needs
but is 169 just for this biennium or
just one year apropos representative
Heath was saying we don't want these
projects in the education trust fund all
the time I don't I don't think the
changes in House Bill 2 would be binding
I think it'd be up to any Opera any
budget any legislature to
put the cap or put these in either way
in either House Bill 25 or one and two
operating or capital okay so let's don't
jump around again let's raise our hands
on 169 and 170 because they're
they're tied to each other
is everybody in favor of 169 or 170.
yeah
[Music]
yes
okay Miss Kate oh okay all right so see
Mickey 69 and 70. or thumbs up okay
excellent
hey we made some progress uh so uh
171 identifies what the government is
recommending
yeah so 171 uh 172 is the two percent
annual versus the CPI I have a feeling
this committee is probably going to
support that based on so but it's going
to be probably part of a bigger
Amendment if you do an education trust
fund anyone but that provision would
remain so I I'm reluctant to just cherry
pick different components here because I
feel like there could be one Amendment
that's just going to overwrite all these
sections and we may keep some things in
take some things out
so you would like to know which ones
where
I mean I'm not I don't know if we're in
a place to do that
um because so the first one 171
increasing the per people eight amounts
I don't think we're settled on that yet
right the two percent I think we are
probably okay with that yep the repeal
of relief funding I don't think so these
are the the
this is the component that would be
based on free and reduced lunch
populations the next is the change to
the extraordinary needs Grant when it
goes out 10 years the next is where the
hold harmless and stabilization Grant
are edited
um
I don't think we're in a place to do any
of those three these are bridges we
can't cross yeah I think the only one
that is probably okay is 170 so 176 is
relative to Charters and we're going to
hold the representative Mooney Amendment
until that settles 177 you probably are
okay with this is uh repealing a
Statewide education Improvement
Assessment program data relative to
third grade reading which I think was
tied to the component that you're
probably going to be okay with taking
out of adequacy everybody concur no I
have a question
um I'm thinking of the rather
unpleasantness around all the Amendments
that came in with was the HB 49 that we
had four different amendments or so
somewhat conflicting with each other
some that were the same with each other
I would prefer to see us go to the full
Finance board with one Amendment that
deals with all of this
but I don't know if we can take out
these until I yeah I'm probably still
going to keep them blank on here because
when your final decision is made it'll
be one Amendment that's going to
override all these it'll just include
some of the same Provisions as the
governor
same thing so education trust fund
distribution and allowable uses this
committee had talked for a while about
expanding Contracting you know what what
programs would be out of the education
trust fund I
don't know if we're at a point today to
go through those or support that
probably should just hold off for now
okay uh which one is that uh some sorry
one uh 64 section 164.
now down at the bottom under amendments
we have uh
Department of Education data analyst
position
is that is that another we adopted that
one I know but is that is that another
oh they did this was a bit yeah this was
House Bill 542. okay and uh we had heard
from the Department relative to that and
we did we do have an amendment in here
and so we'll capture that spend in
establishing that position I don't know
if you want to talk about Medicaid
direct certification we have
representative Heath and Petrie's
Amendment which is uh zero eight seven
nine h
which is on page 24 of your packet
yeah I think we approved that yep
thank you
yeah yeah I I don't think we did a show
of hands or anything on this one I think
we discussed that this would be
something the committee would entertain
but I still have this as a pending
Amendment well I think we all those that
agree that we should get in the queue
for this one
yeah okay
done
so so the question on this also is
there's no requirement you do this but
the Department of Education did identify
000 of related costs associated with
pursuing the direct certification uh
let me see I think that that was when
when we got authorized for it no so the
real cost the bigger cost will happen
next budget next biennium that's when
you'll see F and R numbers be adjusted
for direct certification if it happens
in order to get to that point the
department had identified some contract
costs and a uh
position perhaps I think there's a
position associated with it in their
nutrition area as well as it could
change the general fund match that we do
for
um yeah thank you Mark School breakfast
so while adequacy won't be impacted
until fiscal 26 the free and reduced
lunch eligible kids could happen as
early as fiscal 25 but if you remember
adequacies a year behind with accounts
so if those kids are first recognized in
25 there's a state match for breakfast
that'll hit in 25 but adequacy won't
happen until 26 because it's a year
behind so that's the 335 000 relative to
that amendment that I would add in house
bill to if the committee was okay with
that
I feel like that they were it was in the
fiscal note relative to this bill it's
it's cost the department has identified
right along to pursue this okay
so I'll make that change in house bill
one
let's see
we have a show of hands on that one with
the money okay okay
I don't if you want to get that for me I
mean it's going to be the
go ahead did we um cover page 56 section
159 the suspension relative to
appropriations of the highway funds
page it's like the second page in our
packet yeah page 56 section 159.
that's an open item yeah I'm trying to
remember why we were holding on this one
oh it's page to spin the packet oh oh
sorry page um 56
sections 159 Mickey Mouse so in in law
there's statutory limits for what can be
budgeted as far as Highway funds to dot
safety and other agencies so Department
of Safety head and House Bill 2
requested that a suspension of their
provision be in there I think as a belt
and suspenders just in case their budget
ended up being out of compliance you're
not out of compliance as of right now
and I'll monitor that so if we don't
need that section we'll delete that
we'll keep that one until we're closed
up with the highway fund
and uh as we're going through these and
I know we've decided on some there's a
couple open Adam is here too if we've
heard from agencies on a lot of these
things but we hadn't heard from the
governor's office on specifically many
of these things so if you do need him by
all means
so I know I I think that I don't know if
I don't think there was a consensus on
the computer science stuff but um I just
want to speak to that for a second that
um I believe those are General funds our
legal counsels back there but
um those are I believe those are General
funds and so I I don't think that would
have a trust fund impact
um I we think it's important to increase
the number of stem and computer science
Educators uh here in the state and what
this does is provide grants and a new
credentialing pathway for them so if a
computer science teacher or a teacher
pursues pursues a credential in computer
science they could get some professional
uh funds for that professional
development funds as well as
once they get that certification if they
teach computer science for uh three
years then they would get grants
um or bonuses if you will so in the
first year would be five thousand the
following two years it would be 2500
each year and the idea is to increase
the number of uh stem Educators in the
state
um I know it's a it's something the
governor wants to do so that's why that
was included as part of it and
um I'll take questions on that first and
well why would it come out of General
funds
I believe that's the way we wrote it in
in the uh Bill itself
it's a charge to the fiscal 23 Surplus
if you will that's yeah oh okay it's a
charge against 23.
correct
which one which number we want we are on
52 through 60 or 62 through 65 sorry
um if there are no other questions I
just want to jump into the
interoperability lab
um that's a
that's an appropriation that's a
one-time appropriation the idea behind
that is businesses will come in and and
it'll be self-sustaining so I I just
wanted to make that that plug because
um it wouldn't be an ongoing cost so I
just wanted to make sure that was no
yeah go ahead
that's also fiscal 23 Surplus
gender it's also 23 Surplus and it was
for Staffing
that's why I wanted to get up here and
answer questions because I know
yeah yeah
that one's in 23 or the others
established in 20 Surplus uh all of
these there's all those the ones that we
just talked about computer science and
um interoperability lab those are all
Surplus
um favorite way to spend money I believe
the way more is also yes it is that's
right for the record James Scully a
legal counselor of the governor's office
that's correct
you do an attorney Scott doing well
representative how are you
okay
you're on
and just happy that you're happy to
answer any questions on other ones that
you're making changes to
um yeah I I wanted to just provide that
background that some of this is Surplus
so I it does not affect the trust fund
um Appropriations at all uh or or the uh
the amount in the trust fund so I'm
happy to answer any questions on other
ones that you that you did not get
sufficient answers from the Departments
I
know short people
um
they're full though I love it's coming
out of the Surplus
um my favorite money it's not going to
come out of the general fund though
it is it is so it's going to take away
from
the amount of general fund money we can
spend in Surplus in Surplus yeah so we
have a we have a surplus of a projected
surplus of General funds this is coming
out of the 2023 Surplus that we that we
have so has it been established if I may
has it been established how much
division two has to spend in that Arena
that is not a question for me I don't
know
we know
I think
it's gonna be a problem I would assume
that sure would have said something to
me
it's hard to track because I don't know
what the other divisions have done today
but going into today based on your
revenues and based on the decisions to
date across the three divisions we're
actually dipped into the negative for
23. so we're if everything happens with
all the decisions made with the bills
that are out there that are being
supported so that that was emailed to
everybody this morning Mike Kane sent a
a little sheet to that so
um but that's an ever-changing situation
because there could be Cuts being made
in the other divisions right now that
change that for all I know so every
every night at the end of each
division's work you know Mike gain will
tally it up and update
so uh Mick just does that change
um the 96 million on a surplus statement
this is general fund so under under
current law the way it works is any any
general fund service education trust I'm
sorry yeah any any general fund Surplus
at the end of the biennium would go to
the rainy day fund up to the cap so a
lot of these Appropriations you see in
House Bill 2 are spending that money
that otherwise would go to the rainy day
fund so that it's above and beyond what
was projected at the last last biennium
the the last one that I think you um
mentioned before we got up here was the
Civics one that's also
um that is also Surplus okay
looking at that email we have a surplus
of 50 and about 160 millions of requests
across all three divisions for the
Surplus so um
you know that whole Surplus thing may
not work very well for us you know
just while Mickey mentioned yeah
understood I just thought it was
important to um you know compare it to
the other things in the right in the
appropriate bucket that's all
hearing that
uncomfortable changing uh the money
that's going into the education trust
fund um it seems like there's going to
be to cover what we want to do uh we're
going to need all that is in the trust
fund so I'm a little concerned about the
65 to 35
um reappropriation of that money
oh
well I know the chair the Chairman's is
very interested in moving in that
direction yeah
so I'd be very reluctant to
do anything on that in this group until
I talk to him about it
yeah
so I'm not sure I'm sorry oh sorry no I
think
it is related but all I was like gonna
say is that changing funding from one
pocket to another does not change the
bottom line it just changes the way it's
restricted that's all so yeah that's
partially true
yeah
yeah it's a one-way Street into the
education
okay any other items
so one item that we've been hanging on
to here is the retirement system
eligibility for ccsnh employees hired
after one January I don't know if you
wanted to ask the governor's office that
because I don't think we got much of an
explanation
sorry section six and seven on page two
of House Bill two right at the top under
ccnh I was curious if um if there's the
option of going to another retirement
fund what that does to the current
retirement fund does it put it more at
risk it seems like it would
okay
I believe we we'd probably have to check
out with the retirement system I I would
assume that it would but we would have
to check with them
oh they they could be moving from
retired contribution to
move from repair
ah benefit
specified benefits defined benefit
defined contribution benefit to Define
contribution a minute
which seem smart to do that
yeah
if anything that move in the long term
will decrease the amount of fund spent
because again defined benefit plans ends
up costing more than the defined
contribution plans in the short term if
we take people who are going to end up
in the retirement system and put them
into a non-state retirement system then
here's the number of people going into
the retirement system will be lower but
also our liability for the people we are
putting in will be even lower than that
so in the short term we'll have to move
money from one pocket to another to pay
for the retirement system but in the
long term this will save money and also
give those people you know a lot of
comfort in terms of they know exactly
what they put in and what's theirs and
so on
this is a community college
so that we could take action on this
I object to it
I don't know what it is so I'm I just
made it up we're happy to get back to
you with some answers on on that
um we we have others in the office who
who are sort of experts in this so we
can we can get back to you with it with
a good answer on that and we had Shannon
in here this morning so we could have
she left at three
maybe she'll be back Monday we'll we'll
ask you something I'm sure she will
so so doesn't doesn't this put the
community college employees into the
state retirement system or it's a
completely different system
takes them out
if if no it doesn't take a current
employee out it takes people who are
hired after this start date yeah
yeah it says hired after January 24
right
okay
so we'll wait for an explanation just to
we're all Insurance experts in
retirement experts the next the next set
would be page three so we do have a lot
of open requests from agencies
um
I don't know if any of those questions
that you'd like to present to the
governor's office they're still all
pending none of them are necessarily
required or tied to House Bill 2 in any
way these are just mainly the additional
prioritized needs that were presented
when the agencies came to see us
yeah I I what I would say is you know we
we paired we paired hp2 and HP one back
to to what we thought was the most
appropriate
um and if there are additional needs
above and beyond that I think it would
be up to the agencies to to answer those
specific questions uh more adequately
than than us but uh if there's something
specific in there that you want more
answers to I'm sure I can get an answer
pretty quickly
um you know within the next 24 hours or
so
well we don't know where we are so it's
kind of tough to say we can spend this
and we're going to spend that
this looks to me like the 11th Hour
consideration of all the these extra
requests are kind of like the last dish
yeah and it's and it's possible so the
and I'm unsure
I think most of these would have been
presented to the governor governor's
office when crafting their budget and
didn't make it so I'd say these would be
decisions that
um for the most part there's a couple
new requests uh for instance uh you know
I'm looking at the fish and game
requests that they recently came forward
with right
um that would have probably been
discussed during the governor's budget
but I'm not sure what happened there
um and we did
uh I'm trying to remember there was one
other late request so I went for doe but
we took care of those already
so these are The Cutting Room floor
items
uh some of them some of them we've seen
before some of them uh you know I think
are probably new requests making Mickey
mention
um my my sense is the the agencies would
be best to answer those just because uh
I don't have all the all the details
behind all of them uh in front of me so
but if there's again if there's a
specific one or a few that you want
answers to feel free to reach me I'll be
working over the weekend and I can get
some answers
it seems right now that we can't do much
with this unless until we know what our
money is going to be you know this is
with safety and transportation
um it seems as though we've covered you
know the basic budget of these
organizations these agencies and this is
the above and beyond and once we know if
we have any above and beyond we can fill
into here well I know we were 88 million
dollars
under in our forecast I'm looking at
some of these numbers they're they're
all
at least five digits yeah so some of
them are six so it's like uh yeah looks
like cutting one floor is going to win
again
so we'll head until the first of the
week hopefully uh over the weekend we'll
have a better sense of where the three
divisions are at after work through
today and maybe the chair will either
allocate targets or something for each
division and we'll have a clear pathway
Monday okay yeah
I just wanted to check we were planning
to meet on Saturday or not you've made
references to meeting on Monday now so I
just want to make sure I'm on the same
page I don't know there's much we can do
that we haven't done
because in that go ahead yeah we don't
have anything scheduled for tomorrow and
I think there'd be a big coordination
effort to get the building open with
facilities and security and I.T to
stream so I don't think that it was an
option at this point so that that's even
better so so we're we're back to Monday
Monday at 10 o'clock and as you probably
all saw uh we have full committee exec
session scheduled Monday at one which uh
is what it is so we may lose Monday
afternoon or most uh we can recess in
the morning with the opportunity to come
back in the afternoon if you get done
quick across the hall but I'm not sure
how quick it's going to go we went
through uh the last time we execed bills
I don't remember how many we had but
that that didn't take an hour but most
of them are routine right
well these are all in this all except
one are division one we have one one
item in there
just a quick thing again in terms of how
much we are doing
23 is in a deficit
you know 24 25 in a surplus of 50 with
160 million in requests
25 sir plus 96 with over 200 million
requests so I'm not looking anything
that we add we'll have to cut something
else from and more so please you know
keep that in mind I mean it's we're
gonna have to ceiling it ain't gonna be
pretty
so what for today anything else
yeah we I I think we authorized the
General funds to make up the shortfall
for a fishing game and I think we did
they do have it for this year there's
still a sufficient Surplus uh the
question is you know it'd be nice to
help them out but it's looking like we
might not be able to but they have
enough yeah they've got enough to cover
what they want to do I believe
so so to clarify that request they have
the authorization for the positions and
the funding it's just they're funded
they want to switch the funding from two
of them from Fish and Game to General
funds so the Surplus statement that you
have on page eight of your packet for
fishing game presents a four and a half
million dollar even Gap adjusted Surplus
at the end of the biennium which is a
healthy position considering what it was
a decade ago it's just you can see going
back from 23 to the end of 25. it's uh
significantly you know just like highway
just like education there's an operating
deficit there so we're chipping into the
the fund balance to balance this budget
they can absorb it they will just say
that it probably creates issues moving
forward
so they start flying close to the plane
but the end of the next way
based on the revenues how they're
tracking and their expenditures yes I
would say that's that's the case
so I I guess that's about it
so we'll recess
I'd say at this point recess just in
case but we're probably
10 o'clock Monday at 10 o'clock but
we'll still recess just in case
foreign